in a shocking revelation
it turns out that Joe Biden had
classified documents at his UPenn office
oh boy classified documents I mean
that's criminal isn't it he's gonna have
to be arrested he's gonna have to first
impeached then convicted then criminally
charged oh wait you can't criminally
charge a sitting president I guess oh
well we'll see what happens I'm gonna no
I'm not gonna hold my breath waiting for
Democrats to actually come out and say
anything negative about Joe Biden it's
not surprising that we're now hearing a
similar story classified documents I
mean we saw it with Hillary but they're
not going to call for any accountability
it's not going to happen they're going
to throw it under the rug so uh we'll
we'll just sit back watch and then laugh
knowing that nothing will come of it
however we have another story that's
really interesting emails released
showing that uh I guess it looks like
the bite Administration was trying to
get Tucker Carlson banned among other
things Pfizer was lobbying Twitter as
well so that's interesting and then this
weekend yo it was crazy the January 8th
is basically January 6 in Brazil now
Brazilian stormed into the capital to
the Congress and the Supreme Court and
the media is saying Trump inspired it so
uh
here we go all right everybody before we
get started head over to timcast.com
become a member subscribe by clicking
that join us button support our work
directly and you'll get access to
exclusive members only shows from this
podcast uncensored every night we put
them up around 11 or so p.m not so
family friendly but definitely worth a
listening with your support we're gonna
do a whole bunch of fun crazy stuff like
this Saturday
in DC at Freedom Plaza I'm gonna be
skating and I want to see all of you
there we're going to get a van we're
going to load it up with a whole bunch
of decks skateboard decks I think we've
got like maybe 30 or so step on snack
and find out skateboards we've maybe got
30 or so Tim cast skateboards we're
gonna give them all away for free we're
literally I'm gonna pull up in the
corner back who wants a free board and
then uh I don't know maybe some other
free stuff and then we're all gonna
skate and so I'm gonna bring me the boys
we're gonna go down there we have a good
Skate Session nothing political just
literally skateboarding DC Freedom Plaza
show up I'll probably be there around 10
a.m I'm immediately gonna give away a
whole bunch of free stuff and uh if you
want to board we'll give it out and um
it should be a good uh good good day of
fun hope to see you there with your
support we'll do more stuff like this
I'll get into that story in a little
like explaining why we're doing it and
what's going on and uh but just know
that uh I'm not here to back down when
when the woke mob years it's ugly head
I'm gonna I'm here to mind my business
and do what I want to do and that means
if I want to go skate in DC I'm going to
go skate in DC and ain't nobody can tell
me otherwise so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member like I
said joining us today it's going to be a
fun show we got the Hodge twins here we
got the cameras got to pick one of you
guys I don't know the same person who
are you same person
I'm Kevin if you can't tell us apart all
right but so the so the made in America
shirts Kevin yeah yeah
yeah we should have saved money and just
flew one of them out here yeah and then
and then just double the cameras up
right so what do you guys do who are you
for those that don't know I think
everybody knows who you are but uh we're
known as the conservative twins on
YouTube yeah uh we came up politically
about four or five years ago but before
that we had been on YouTube maybe about
10 years doing Fitness talk talking
about current events giving relationship
advice yeah yeah
but now most of all everybody knows
about our politics yeah right on
unfortunately the reason why we came out
um politically is of course we black and
we want to show blacks that hey you
don't have to think a certain way you
can be conservative as well but
unfortunately we end up gentrifying a
whole audience so yeah yeah well there
you go I guess I remember I remember I
remember when we first came out when we
had a comedy show in Nashville right and
I looked outside so like I think these
people at the wrong show yeah yeah I had
a a a a a a fan basis turned overnight
man it's crazy really like people left
you behind or what yeah it was like a
good mix we got it we gotta we gotta
talk about this because the reason I'm
doing the skate thing has a lot to do
with something similar so we'll talk
about all this stuff it's crazy times
thanks for hanging out man it's gonna be
fun it's gonna be funny we got lucr
hanging out hey guys my name is we are
change.org and as you know there's a lot
of dynamic Duos out there we got the
Hodge twins here there's the island boys
in there of course there's also the real
Island Boys which I think are worth
paying attention to rumor is it that
they're still partying out there if you
want to bring them more attention to the
real party boys as depicted on my shirt
you can on the best politicalshirts.com
and because you do that's why I am here
thank you again so much for having me hi
everybody Ian Crossland here uh Ian
crossel.net what's the item let's just
keep rolling this along how are you
Serge tell me about it hey I'm doing
good I'm at surge.com I dot search.com
people were telling me that they were
going to search.com I don't own that I'm
just searched.com spell it out it's not
too hard anyways so you don't actually
have the website no but now I'm like I'm
like I shouldn't get like surge.com like
spellout.com that's a good idea yeah why
not yeah all right let's talk about this
news from the post-millennial breaking
classified documents from Biden's time
as VP discovered in his UPenn office
whoa whoa whoa classified documents we
heard that Donald Trump classified
documents and they the FBI raided his
house all right wow I mean the FBI is
going to have to raid uh Joe Biden right
I do not believe for a second the FBI
raided his house looking for classified
doctors I think it was just a fishing
Expedition oh I agree for sure but
they're not going to rate Joe Biden at
all for any reason so you know yeah in
his defense he probably just forgot to
do it though
but it's a vegetable no but for real
like he probably just forgot they were
there yeah like even even if Trump had
classified documents it's probably just
absent-minded it's like we grabbed a box
we carried it out we were moving out
they turned it into a federal case
Chicago attorney has been assigned by
U.S attorney general Merrick Garland to
review classified documents found at the
Penn Biden Center for diplomacy and
Global engagement in Washington reports
CBS News it relates to about 10
documents from Biden's Biden's vice
presidential office
now see I I isn't it that's that's like
that's disqualifying as as a public
office as an enlightened that's at least
it so statistically speaking has been in
his office at least six years at least
six probably longer yeah probably longer
yeah he's the forgetful guy I mean it
happens right you lose a paper there and
there and then you know you press the
red button and holy cow we have nuclear
but that's a whole nother subject to get
into another interesting fact about what
we're seeing being reported today was
that these documents were actually found
uh a day before the mid to term
elections and we're hearing about it
right now this is the doj is also
considering pressing charges against
Donald Trump for of course having his
classified documents Donald Trump by the
way just sent out a message to everyone
on Truth social saying quote when is the
FBI going to raid the many homes of Joe
Biden perhaps even the White House
probably not anytime soon since of
course the FBI pretty much is working as
the own private Stasi of the White House
and uh essentially being very busy
Banning people especially on social
media for their speech that they
disagreed with so I don't see that
happening anytime soon I don't know what
you guys think that'd be like a scene
out of South Park if they rented the
White House yeah yeah they should I mean
look why not they shouldn't I'll be
honest going after Donald Trump was
wrong yeah rating him over this is his
total BS yeah but if this is the
standard that the Democrats and the FBI
want to play by then uh we expect Joe
Biden to get right I mean this is this
from when he was vice president
so that calls into question eligibility
if they want to play this game that it's
illegal to take classified documents
like they did for Trump and they wanted
to argue that it disqualified him for
running again remember this they were
putting out those memes where they were
like Trump can't run for president now
that he's been uh caught with these
documents oh this is an interesting
thing about Joe Biden there you're
saying huh yeah but that always kind of
happens I mean if they didn't do
anything for Hillary Clinton's private
email server they're not going to do
anything here I mean it's pretty clear
it's pretty obvious I mean what else do
you expect the FBI to do yeah it should
be obviously anybody with a brain that
they treat conservatives Republicans
totally different than what they do to
liberals so obvious double standard
nobody wants to point it out especially
when they left well yeah but so what do
you guys say to people like your friends
and your family when they don't believe
you when you look when you you show them
a story like this like here's the FBI
rating Trump's home yeah here's some
saying nothing's going out with Joe
Biden like how do you well I know but I
just don't even have that conversation
anymore because you're like yeah during
Christmas
that's the best time to have those
conversations yeah it was it was my
father-in-law and he's like he's like um
he brought up Trump he said man that got
Trump he's like Hitler I was like what I
was like you said did you see what they
did at the capital it was crazy that's
like
bruh but um
how did you counter how did that
conversation go I was just nice about it
because English is not his first
language my wife is from uh Jalisco Mako
he's a real nice guy he's just that uh I
think people don't understand that the
typical American that's not into
politics when they turn on the news they
just believe it that guy's is in a suit
he's uh he's a journalist he's not gonna
lie to me you know what I mean so a lot
of people fall for it so I just told him
I said he's not a bad guy he might be an
[ __ ] but he's not a bad guy he's not
Hiller I was like do you know what
Hitler did yeah but this is a scary
thing that I've been talking about all
day it's like we have to have
conversations and try to bring regular
people like that into understanding
otherwise we're going to see kids
they're growing up and they're not
hearing these ideas at all these kids
are going to get older and they're
they're only thing they're going to know
is wokeness there's not going to be an
argument their whole world view is built
upon one idea because the other
conversation is not happening yeah but
so many people in this country is Out Of
Tune with politics they don't vote yeah
they don't I mean they get a glimpse
here and there like how many people
actually voted in this past election
in my country it's what was it like 58
or 60 it was actually pretty high
relatively like more and more people are
getting politically active which is a
good thing I think which is great but
it's like 40 of these countries just
they're just tuned out they don't yeah
no uh journalist last election during uh
you know when Bob won the presidency
um he had some counties that actually
was pretty hot they said like a hundred
percent of the people turned out to vote
some places more than 100 yeah you know
it's crazy that's amazing they were
saying I guess that because of covid
people moved and that caused a shock to
the system where like more than a
hundred percent of registered voters are
turning up but I'm not you know it's
funny
what happened Joe Patton's a superstar
man yeah 81 million votes and he'd even
campaign yeah he was he was in the
basement all the time yeah he wasn't
showing up I don't think we can beat him
the next election yeah well no but
here's how can you here here's the thing
about that we were talking about before
the show about like Revenue viewership
and everything in 2020 was really high
the pandemic made everything very very
weird so I think I think one of Biden's
biggest advantages was he didn't need to
campaign because it was a culture war
and they forced everybody into it they
took away your movies you can go to
movies you can go to sporting events you
couldn't even leave your house and they
told you it was Donald Trump's fault
then they had to do a mail-in ballot
right so being in the basement was
relatable to a lot of people right you
know he's staying there yeah I'm doing
that too this is my guy right here I
think Hunter helped him a lot too he's
famous yeah yeah a lot of photos a lot
of videos of that guy he's a great
symita verite artist and uh he also
started a YouTube channel
Freedom
hey that's not that's true yeah like he
was like his girlfriend or his wife
threw a gun in a garbage can and get in
trouble yeah yeah like wow
right near school yeah who can have
drugs and a gun and nothing happens
[Laughter]
I kind of would love to watch a hunter
Biden YouTube channel yeah could you
imagine vlogging every day he'd have
amazing subscribers in a week in a week
yeah yeah he's at a club his shirts off
and he's just like shaking he's got
white powder across it to his face
people are gonna be like this is awesome
like try to do something now
try to arrest me now it's like how he
goes legitimate is that he creates a
YouTube channel around his Antics and
then doesn't need to take corrupt money
from foreign businesses or anything like
that you know but give him any ideas man
I mean look Hunter Biden doing YouTube
videos means he's not doing Club
business deals I'll take it you know and
we'll have a good time we'll laugh
what's this educational background I
know he got kicked out of military for
for drugs I think I'm not sure what his
education background is he's had some
very significant jobs that people would
die for yeah like he was uh on the a
board a board member of barisma an
energy company in Ukraine don't even
speak the language yeah
it's like me going to Mexico I don't
speak anything friends and I'm over I'm
on the board of an energy company you
don't speak a lick of Spanish a black
guy
but like actually think about it they're
going to be sitting there in a meeting
and they're all going to be speaking
Spanish and you're gonna be like okay
see
and then uh and then your your dad shows
up and uh demands the president fire a
prosecutor who's investigating your
company it's on tape
they're bragging about it you know
what's crazy they've been investigating
Trump ever since being before he became
president they've been investing a gate
net man every day of the year for like
the last five six years can we just
investigate Biden for one day just one
day spend like fifty dollars I think I
think they're talking about doing
something not not gonna necessarily
trust McCarthy and the rest of the
Republicans but they're talking about
the I think Jim Jordan's doing heading
up a committee on the weaponization of
government right yeah so you know
fingers crossed I don't know how much
which is a real thing oh yeah yeah I
mean the one thing we talk about all the
time is that a bunch of pro-lifers got
arrested by the feds for being at
abortion clinics but the protesters
protesters who show up to Kavanaugh and
Amy Cody Barrett's house no problem even
though it's like well come on like
where's there's there's no yeah it's
just it's com it's completely lopsided
and you mentioned it earlier yeah yeah
it is it's a government is like so
corrupt it's like it's not even yeah I
used to thought our country was like I
mean our country is better than most I
think it's the best country we travel
all over you although we're Australia
learning I mean it's no more it's no and
we got so many more opportunities here I
mean like when we went to Australia
London they're talking about U.S
politics 24 7. yeah that's weird they're
talking about Trump in Australia that's
weird yeah yeah and we went to Canada
man the ladies just we had a comedy show
she was probably from head to toe yeah
it's like everything in the world
evolves around the United States of
America yeah a lot of people want to be
here too yeah oh yeah have you had a
check out the uh Southern border that's
right everybody yeah the crazy thing
about that is you get people coming from
Africa they'll fly from Africa to Brazil
and then take trains and convoys up to
the United States border yeah and then
you get the left acting like it's you
know just refugees I'm like bro they had
like six thousand dollars to do that
yeah yeah that's a lot of money yeah
yeah somebody's financing that I don't
how did some dude who lives in Western
Africa yeah save up three grand per
person yeah to fly to Brazil yeah then
take this trip up and pay the pay the
Smugglers and the traffickers
it's crazy it's a system set up yeah I'm
sure as hell not walking 3 000 miles
like they make it out to me yeah they
run on top of trains and stuff yeah
that's like walking from here that's
like walking from Virginia to California
that's 2 000 miles yeah they saying they
walk in three thousand miles there's no
way yeah
so what do we do
meditate that helps me yeah it helps you
kind of like be okay with it I guess you
know what I mean like you yeah but also
when the rubber hits the road if the
wheels are spinning too fast it's just
you get no traction so it's good to kind
of reorient and realize that life is
actually pretty good regardless of the
chaos yeah we still have a goodness kind
of the state of the best country in the
world we could be doing so much better
though but yeah well that just can't be
cruises I guess I think
I'm optimistic but I see a dark future
in front of us because let's get into
this one right now because you guys were
talking a moment ago about you know like
you your fan base flipped on you you
want to explain like what happened you
guys were doing Fitness content on
YouTube and yeah it used to be very
young
you see a bunch of bodybuilders yeah and
fit chicks it was a good uh mix it's
like yeah
15 20 would be like black probably yeah
I mean we'll we've always had a majority
white audience because we live in a
white country but it was a good mix it
was a it showed it it uh it represented
what America is right now it's just yeah
like it looks like we had a Bruce
Springsteen concert there's a whole
bunch of white dudes yeah when I it's it
totally blew me away because when we had
a show in Knoxville we look out to the
arms that's like you see a bunch cowboy
hats us like I think these people at the
wrong time yeah yeah I didn't know I
mean I mean since we came out of the
closet that's concerned I didn't think
it was I thought
for the most part we was committing
career suicide but we just fed up we was
just so pissed off by how the direction
of the country and yeah and then but
then we had no idea people was going to
come out and support us the way they did
you know what's crazy when we go out
before our comedy shows we get a
standing ovation wow yeah so you guys
actually thought it was done you're like
we're gonna say this that's the end of
it yeah yeah I had no idea what's going
to take off the way it did there's the
best decision we ever made and you know
it's a lot of places they want books
because we're conservative but the
comedy clubs that do book us man the
staff the uh the management team like
man these people are tipped so good you
guys can come back it's like they spend
money they tip well they're real uh
cultural for everybody and then there's
some clubs to where they treat our fans
like [ __ ] I never go back there wow yeah
yeah I want to give a shout out to uh
ex-cal shooting range and fitness and uh
sports fitness shooting in uh Virginia
we went there this weekend everyone
there was super cool if you're like
shooting guns man shout out because they
were very very nice to us yeah super
awesome I hope so they got Goods that's
right that's right and I'm like I don't
don't think I think if you're if you're
in a position where you're in the
business of guns you you've you've got
to choose your friends as loudly as
possible because if you're not speaking
up for your rights they've been coming
after you for a long time yeah an armed
Society is a very polite society and
yeah I I think you know the stats in
Chicago especially with crime uh show
that very well yeah uh but yeah shout
out to xcal great guys uh great facility
uh lots of firearms lots of like really
fun stuff to shoot full auto yeah I had
a lot of fun there this weekend as well
so what's your favorite gun what's your
favorite paper
um it depends I mean what are we doing I
mean 300 Blackout uh sugar weasels are
also pretty cool
I'm a bonding guy I got a shotgun they
had uh they have cameras on the range
right and I'm walking out to grab some
of our our crew to bring them in and I
and I'm like oh there's Luke and you can
see Luke in the camera in the range and
you can't hear anything and he's just
going like this yeah like like
explaining the machine gun but uh but
the reason I I was asking about it is
because I mentioned earlier that we're
gonna do this big skate thing uh on
Saturday I shouldn't even call it a big
skate thing I just said literally I'm
gonna go and skate because you know I'm
just sick and tired of hearing this over
and over and over again and look I got a
lot of friends who are in the skateboard
industry that people I've known for
decades people have known since I was a
kid and they're all doing this thing
where they're like hey man I really
agree with everything you say but like I
I you know I can't I can't tell anybody
that of course and I'm like I'm like I
hate that get out of here dude like look
that's like such a smacking so what
happened what what uh what galvanized
you to do this event with the skateboard
well look man like I don't want to call
an event I'm just gonna say okay I'm
gonna be there so we've gone skating
around all the parks in this area right
never had an issue they opened up a new
park to a park in Hagerstown Maryland no
issue I show up I'm skating people come
up to me they're fist bumping me they're
shaking my hands they're like oh dude
like cool man cool this is really
awesome then I go to DC and apparently
like something happened I don't even
know what because I don't really even
know anybody there well it's DC that's
DC yeah but it's all money my own
business and there was like a couple
people that I I like one guy sort of new
and there are a couple people there who
are like you know famous and I'm just
like oh wow look at this guy and I'm
just like talking to locals no problem
but apparently some people had some some
beef and started like sending out texts
into the into the community saying
something I don't even know exactly what
necessarily listen because you're white
yeah yeah yeah actually they were wider
than I was right and so uh they were The
Good Wife that's right that's how it
goes right so me being uh you know like
supposedly this diverse visual of a
mixed race background showing up to
skate my own business I got white people
attacking me now but I'm the white
supremacist that bad guys but so I was
just like dude
I live here man we live in the DC area I
skate here there's no reason for
anything to be said about anything I'm
on my own business I'm gonna go do what
I want I'm gonna skate I'm do what I
want yeah and so the issue is you guys
mentioned that your audience flipped it
I thought that was interesting for me
what's what's happened is I found that
most the people who followed me
still do but they message me probably be
like oh yeah I just can't I can't I
can't let anybody know and then I'm like
here's gonna happen
there's a little kid right now he's 10
years old he's not heard of free speech
at all because you won't speak up so
when he goes to the skate park the only
thing he hears is wokeness right and
then you just keep your mouth shut like
a good little like a good little nugget
servant marching behind behind the woke
people it was helping them to their ends
I'm not going to do that that's what
feeds it nobody's speaking up that's
right so that's that's that's that's
kind of uh you know Bravo you guys
demanded um just because you might have
different opinions in politics while
people will
I don't know it's just it's just it's a
cult yeah it's a lack of courage in this
country but it's like it seems like it's
when people get afraid when they start
to panic is when the politics becomes
divisive if they're not in a panic state
right I've never noticed that in the
last 40 years right you're absolutely
fun it's actually fun to talk politics
yeah yeah and that's why I think your
story your guys's story is so important
here because you know you guys also had
that fear before coming out and actually
being the truest versions of yourselves
being actually authentic not being
afraid to actually speak your mind and
once you're living freely there's
there's the kind of softness there's a
kind of easiness going around life being
like hey I'm not gonna have to you know
think about what I'm gonna have to say
here I'm just gonna say what I want you
to say living that life is amazing and
sadly a lot of people listening to this
right now are holding themselves back
they're afraid to say anything they're
afraid to intervene they're afraid to
have those conversations and I think
they're being stupid yeah right yeah
it's a liberating experience once you do
come out I mean it's liberating for a
gay person to finally come out of the
closet is liberating if you're
conservative just come out and be
yourself it was definitely liberating
for two black guys to come out of the
closet yes conservative so what happened
leading up to it were you getting
frustrated
I got tired of looking at like all these
uh famous black people on social media
with their views I was like man I have a
platform I'm gonna use my platform to
express you know I'm a black guy but I
think this way it's like it's almost
like a culture within a black community
and it is it's like 90 of blacks vote
Democrat every election that is so weird
there's no other demographic in this
country that votes at that clip that 90
yeah it doesn't make it cost to think
the other side is racist they fail for
that yeah what they say and they keep
saying that people on the left that said
uh that we are a threat to democracy the
only threat to the market is when you
lie about the other side and call them
names and I call them transphobia racist
they are the threats to democracy
because you're lying for votes for the
federal government to prosecute them and
to silence their speech on social media
like the White House is doing by
literally telling social media companies
to censor people because of their voices
let me just say that kind of democracy
is like North Korean democracy yeah they
call it the Democratic People's Republic
of North Korea and they all vote and
they all have to vote for the one guy
yeah when you all vote for the exact
same thing that's not democracy yeah so
but here's what you got to understand
when they say you're a threat to our
democracy they're not talking about the
United States as an hour they're talking
about the cult as an hour they're saying
you're a threat to the woke order that's
what they're saying and when they're
calling for diversity they're not
calling for diversity of opinions yeah
right they're just calling for diversity
of the same opinion that they're going
to regurgitate and beat you over the
head with because that's the power
structure that really is kind of
fomenting in this country and getting
more violent and getting more powerful
by the day which is becoming a larger
threat against human
that's why they picked a black woman to
be a jugs because she's a woman and when
she gets up and she doesn't know what
the hell a woman is there was a BS this
woman uh Kirsten Henning I think her
name was she refused to kneel for BLM
and it was a college soccer I think and
uh so they benched her because of it she
just won 100 allegedly she filed a
lawsuit 100 Grand she since left she's
on doing her life hundred thousand
dollars in her pocket nice so I'm
telling people there there was this
college professor who said if you're in
school if you're in work and they start
disparaging white people Christians
males or any of that stuff or
conservatives bring it to HR and file a
complaint because they're not allowed to
do that use their own system against
them like Blackstone protected class
gays are protected class any person of
color is a protected class but I don't
think necessarily you can be
discriminatory towards white people and
you don't have to worry about any civil
rights yeah that's right so what they're
doing yeah yeah that's the culture of
the United States of America right now
which is weird because it's the idea
that a white person has no color it's a
person that isn't no they're saying that
colors did you're actually what they're
saying you are superior yeah yeah thanks
yeah
all right but the best day of my life
this is how um as a black person yeah
I'm telling you that's where it comes
from yeah they think you're Superior I
think it comes from a lot of self-hatred
too they don't think they can do it
because they've been they've been
indoctrinated black person you turn on
TV and you need a white politician
Democrat to help you be successful in
this country that's what Joe Biden said
they want to put y'all back in Chains
yeah I mean 90 that's why 90 of black
people vote Democrat because they think
they need Democrats up because you guys
are evil and are you sure you guys are
black because Joe Biden said if you're
not voting for him you're not really
technically I'm no longer black exactly
so yeah were you guys feeling like the
racism percolate before you got vocal
politically were you feeling that kind
of stuff because it was like under the
radar until 2016. I didn't I wasn't
sensing it I actually did a president
who actually converted me was was uh
Barack Obama he'd actually converted me
I thought when he became president
because I voted for him for his first
turn you know I voted for Al Gore I
voted for Bill Clinton I was raised
Democrat I showed up I voted for Kerry
but you know what I just like yeah yeah
when I went that's Skull and Bones
cousin yeah Barack Obama actually
changed her minds and first time I voted
Republican was for Mitt Romney yeah
believe that [ __ ] like like Barack
because some people have said he's the
was the most racist president of all
time because he would constantly talk
about race yeah yeah yeah yeah I thought
it was a great thing when he got elected
I was like man this is yeah you would
thought like man a black man is
President how far has this country came
in ever since he yeah
turned for the worse in this country
this country is systemically racist but
even though a black man beat two white
men in a country that's what 65 white
yeah with the name Baraka Hussein Obama
yeah and twice yeah a galvanized white
supremacists up on the Rocks Barack
Obama not my country
I mean it just it doesn't make any sense
yeah deporter in Chief that's right
everyone forgot I mean if you voted for
Romney that's technically technically
voting for a Democrat too so yeah yeah
he was my last name yeah McCain the same
way looking back on it now looking back
on it dude do it feel like it was a
setup for him to become president that's
the best thing the Republicans could
admit Romney and McCain yeah it doesn't
mean or they're just not smart people
right but the thing is they're they're
two Elite clubs and they're able to keep
everybody out but they were friends with
Obama of course of course and he was
calling him pretty basically a racist
and they didn't even you see that weird
you see the video from uh from the house
when there's no speaker C-SPAN can show
whatever they want and you've got
Republicans and Democrats fist bumping
and hanging out yeah yeah yeah and then
but then you know many of these people
get up and be like oh these people
across the aisle they don't wanna hey
man I'm just saying and that you know
it's all one big thing it's like George
Collins kind of feel like we stuck in a
Truman Show yeah man I feel that that's
for sure yeah especially on mushrooms
yeah it's the um all the artificial
stuff is very uh obviously built by
humans everything else is like what is
this reality
let me uh let's jump to the story we got
this uh we got the story from Luke
gradkowski over here on Twitter at Luke
we are changed as the emails here are
very revealing as the White House was
lobbying to censor Tucker Carlson and
Tommy Lauren on Facebook so Attorney
General Andrew Bailey of Louisiana says
we now have hard evidence that President
Biden's Administration colluded with
social media companies to censor
differing viewpoints and silence quote
misinformation that was later deemed
true
here's the White House employee s
Twitter to silence Robert Kennedy Jr
here at the Biden White House directs
Facebook to shut down conservative
voices Tucker Carlson and Tommy Loren
and uh more here's the collusion etc etc
I'm kind of I'm kind of surprised I mean
Tucker Carlson's a big name this is this
is a big risk for them Tucker's these
guys got money yeah audacity of them to
try to
censor hey sucker when I think the first
when I think of the word conservatism
republicanism uh the first word the
first face pops in my face
right yeah I used to face some Fox News
when I when I when I think of Fox News I
think of him he's the biggest most
popular news anchor out there and for
the White House to say no we need to
silence him we need to ban him that's a
that's a huge ask that of course
Facebook couldn't officially comply with
but this is this is the documents we're
getting from the Attorney General of
Louisiana that of course is requesting a
lot of these documents this is what
they're making public what aren't they
making public and if the White House is
asking for Tucker Carlson to be taken
down I mean I mean what does that leave
us with right I imagine everyone else I
I think they're they're seeing what they
could get away with I think with these
emails they're like let's just go as far
as we can let's eliminate all voices and
I think Facebook here clearly said hey
we can't go too crazy now we'll give you
almost everything you want but but we
won't give you this and I think this is
a way of also negotiating as well you
always ask for the biggest prize and
then you eat halfway oh we can't get uh
Tucker Carlson oh but we could get uh
Alex Jones or we could get David Ike
let's get those guys okay fine we got it
and they still uh destroyed Free Speech
because this is essentially trampling on
the first amendment in so many different
different instances and uh clear
violation of the law clear abuse of
power and this is what they do in third
world countries this is what they do in
dictatorships so to have this happen
here in America it should be a big
wake-up call to everyone especially with
how much power uh the Democrats are
consolidating for themselves which
they're clearly using against their
political opponents and not against any
kind of legitimate uh you know a bad guy
out there and he's the same people
that's going to bring us the ministry of
truth that's right that's crazy they
tried it and they were here's what they
were doing they've got these
organizations these non-profits that
have Government funding or meet with
people in government then they go the
nonprofits to Big Tech and say you got
to remove these people and big Tech says
oh no this is non-profit giving us
advice it's just you know they're here
for the truth it's just a way the
government Circle events then they tried
doing the actual Ministry of Truth what
were they calling it like you know
Department of disinformation or some
other nonsense that's crazy you go back
and read all the history books anybody
is doing all the sensory turned out to
be the bad guys yeah I knew yeah
tendency towards the US was censoring uh
heavily in World War II we had an office
of censorship the issue is when you're
not allowed to express your opinion on
things right I guess back then in the
United States it was like don't talk
about where our boats are don't talk
about where our troops are going if you
hear someone say like I'm like because
what would happen is some dude would be
like mom being deployed I'm going to
this place and you go wow and then you
go tell somebody but it was never like
you couldn't tell somebody you didn't
like something it used to be that you
weren't allowed to incite like uh panic
in any way so the whole can't shout fire
in a crowded theater uh thing comes from
a guy that was trying to standing
outside and trying to tell people don't
sign up for the draft do not sign up for
the draft don't get drafted for World
War one it was and they were like you
can't do that that's illegal you know so
they arrested the guy went to the
Supreme Court they're like actually you
are allowed to tell people not because
he was making will Panic about signing
up for the military right and that's
total well we're not in a war but but
these emails are specifically related to
the covid-19 vaccine with specifically
the White House saying hey we don't like
what Tucker Carlson is saying about our
product that we're telling everyone to
take that we gave no liability for the
producers of and therefore we need to
take him down since this is a threat
against National Health and in reality
everything that Tucker Carlson was
warning about has essentially come true
and everything that the White House was
claiming uh has essentially been
officially debunked by many scientists
and many scientific studies that have
been coming out and proving it to be
absolutely false I'm optimistic Elon
Musk bought Twitter starts dumping all
the emails and evidence we got this
lawsuit from Louisiana and Missouri and
they're releasing more evidence so it
seems like the machine is is struggling
to keep up with this I wonder if the
White House is still emailing Twitter
though can you please do this just one
more time please give us a hit please
this was part of us something this was
part of the Twitter files even after
Elon took over they were still asking
the people now now they're fired maybe
that's not really going on yeah right
but think about what do you guys think
the emo would look like
it's probably some setup on automation
yeah it's like input name
just like the Vice news articles when
they were throwing uh you know what uh
at the bar to pick up their latest yeah
they have they have an email where it
says greetings uh insert Facebook
employee here this is insert employee
user on on your platform insert username
is being racist and hateful and for this
we believe they violated your rules
please ban insert username now right and
then they can copy and paste how
important is Elon Musk right now man
what he's doing that's why he's
traveling around with arm the guards and
stuff yeah which is amazing because all
he is is trying to protect Free Speech
which is the most important right we
have it's the most that's what made
America America free speech so they're
they're the operating C with the funny
fathers you know they'd have to draft
like Anonymous pamphlets and hand them
out so nobody knew where it was coming
from because they they knew how
important Free Speech was and they were
they were fighting through the
censorship reminds me of Marche you guys
know that guy he's the French basically
one of the founding fathers the French
guy he should be on Mount Rushmore with
the other guys but he was like the guy
that went as in French spy for the
French King to England and then found
out okay the English are beating the
hell out of the Americans in the
revolution so you go back France and
he'd Lie To The King The French King be
like yeah the Americans are winning send
money so then the French got involved
because of Beau marche's lies he got
them and then he was sending his own
personal money uh he set up a fake
company with this other guy in Louisiana
send weapons and armor or weapons and
like uh outfits and stuff but it was
without him you know probably would have
been no American Revolution wow reminds
me Elon because he wasn't an American
citizen right right Fox News had another
article a couple days ago that was
titled musk says U.S government demanded
Twitter suspend a quarter million
accounts including journalists according
to the Twitter file so 250 000 yes 250
000 accounts were uh were demanded to be
suspended by the US government that's a
lot of people sounds like a lot of
services and I bet probably everyone in
this room is on that list yeah I went
down yeah I was blacklisted on Facebook
when I started uh crying about uh covet
when after the covet stuff or no it's
George Floyd and I was like yo George
Floyd had five chemicals in his system
he had fentanyl in the system where
let's talk about fentanyl in his system
behind the wheel of a car driving high
on fentanyl yeah let's talk about that
in Facebook but yeah we're gonna black
yeah Kobe too right yeah
caffeine THC in his system yeah tobacco
you made this point way back when you
were saying that uh a dude high on
Fentanyl and meth a speedball behind the
the steering wheel of the car you got to
stop that person yeah some kids who
knows yeah yeah and you know what um you
know that whole incident when I first
saw it was hard to watch so I didn't
watch the whole video so I made myself
go back and watch it and I started to
analyze everything he said it was crazy
he started saying he couldn't breathe
before he even got to the ground he said
it when he was in the vehicle he was
overdose and I was talking to a bunch of
police officers I run into when we're
doing our shows at airports and things
like that they said they find so many
people dead in jail from the same same
amount of drugs that that man had yeah
so I think it's a possibility he could
have died regardless of he'd wrote a
motorcycle well what got that cop
convicted yeah pretty sure because I
used to catch shoplifters and they told
us certain people old elderly you cannot
be on that chest right
um You got to handle them differently so
I'm sure cops have been trained if
somebody's telling you can't breathe you
don't have them even land on their
stomach that's what got him convicted
the lack of compassion for the guy if
you'd have wrote him over and he died
anyway he wouldn't be in jail all you
have to do is show that little amount of
compassion that's all he had to do yeah
yeah he was already handcuffed there was
no reason to have him sitting right
there I think he was flexing a little
you just Flex them yeah I mean George
was selection of the time no the cop was
flexing because you know at that time
cops was getting all these bad press and
I guess he was like in a moose like I
ain't gotta listen nobody I've been
trained to do this and he stopped
thinking well he got there later I'm in
trouble yeah he did he was the last one
to get there right yeah I was like I
don't know don't care
he did like he knew George from working
together there's a bouncer at a bar was
that a real story came out I know I
don't know if it was real was it real
yeah yeah but look man there's people
that I've worked with I wouldn't
remember you know what I mean like I
worked at a company with 50 employees
you think I remember a single person
well he did George Floyd was like take
me out of the car please put me on the
ground I can't breathe I can't breathe
way before there's any kind of problem
before shove it even got there he said
that yeah and they said okay then
Chauvin shows up and he had Fenton on a
system I mean absolutely the guy was out
of his hand I should have been arrested
for being behind the wheel of a car on
fentanyl yeah just this body reaction
the way he was acting it was like no
grown man that's not how I act like a
big dude he's just saying like I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die he was like saying he
thought he was gonna die before yeah
anything kicked off yeah a while well
anyway Facebook sensors didn't like that
those piece of honest observation yeah
and uh I don't like centralized systems
because like you said Luke was it 200
250 000 accounts yeah that's gonna
happen forever if we leave our social
media networks in centralized systems
it's already happening on uh Facebook on
YouTube on Instagram on WhatsApp take
back all of those other things on Tick
Tock three times um we came this close
to getting banned on Facebook what's
your what is it for uh what did they try
to get hate speech they call the states
we had a million followers on uh Tick
Tock link it's deleted like it was
nothing Tick Tock yeah so you went to
zero three different times come back
yeah not not try again and I got like
four I think 300 but I'm on my last
strike so I just stopped posting is it
what's getting what's getting you banned
on Tick Tock just my same videos I post
on YouTube Facebook same videos we gotta
take them down they say it's hate speech
I posted a video of a transgender female
which is a biological male breastfeed no
no transgender woman yeah transgender
woman sorry thank you thank you yeah
because transgender female is male who
wants to be a man so like yeah someone
born with the yeah no parts so
so she said a breastfeed
I got upper and and I come back to the
video I'm like what the [ __ ] and I said
that's the that's the whole video she's
right there trying to breastfeed it it
didn't kill us
you got banned for that yeah yep it got
removed we got banned from uh from Tick
Tock and they didn't give us a reason
you can post um clips from Fox News but
you can't give a response to it this is
this is what I was talking about when I
was mentioning that we're doing the
skate thing and this is why because all
these these pro skateboarders are like
either they voted for Trump and there's
a ton of that ton of them that did or
they don't like Trump but they just not
woke and they can't stand the wokeness
but none of them will speak up and so
what happens is like with tick tock on
Tick Tock a kid opens it up what do they
see
conservative band whoa so that kid's
gonna grow up and the only thing they're
gonna think is if I'm gonna fit in this
is the way to do it it is reprogramming
all of society right before our eyes
yeah I remember I had to argue with my
daughter when I first came out of
politics um Harry Styles was wearing a
dress
oh yeah and um my daughter's a huge fan
and uh we got into our argument she
started crying
she's just trying to figure out what
comes at the time my daughter was like
13 like why are you crying I'm just
spitting facts here this is not imp
opinions and she started telling me
about
you know God's getting pregnant and I
was like she just didn't know because I
had never sat down with her and she was
on social media so what what did you say
like
I said
I have something about the dressing
being a guy wearing a dress yeah I was
like well that's uh I mean anybody could
wear a dress I was like but I I told her
the reason why he's wearing the dress
she said but he's cute I think it looks
great on him I said no it's no it's not
it doesn't look great on them you're 13.
you don't you're highly impressionable
yeah so it's like she like like people
with Kanye when she came when he came on
here people stood up for Kanye what he
did when he came here when he was
totally in the wrong it's because they
love his music they're biased they're
not thinking she was a huge the Harry
Styles fan and she wasn't listening and
whatever I said it hurt her feelings and
now she's 20 and she's and we was the
same weight growing up looking at
Madonna listen to her music I never
understood what parents is like don't
watch her she's she's Satan you know as
I got older it makes more sense now
these people are put in in positions of
Power with this highly over highly
impressible kids and they're there to
manipulate them and have them think and
act and and I think nowadays both are
certain away
I thought that it was just so improbable
that people were trying to sexualize
Society on purpose that was real then I
started hearing about that I just
learned about this Kinsey guy this uh
learned about a little while ago this
sex doctor from the 1930s 40s 50s and
Hugh Hefner was his student yeah and
they were overtly attempting to
sexualize college kids like they would
go to college campus we are going to
sexualize society so I guess we're still
seeing this yeah the grooming stuff's
real man yeah yeah totally so about the
celebrity stuff I remember I was working
for one non-profit and they were like
I'm a big fan of Death Cab for Cutie and
they said who wants to go see a death
camp concert and I was like are you
kidding and like it was really popular
with college kids at the time and so
they said anybody who volunteers to do
voter registration at the event gets an
all-access pass and I was like I'm done
you tell me where and when they give me
an all-access pass they give me a stack
of voter registration forms and said go
out and just ask people I had to hang
out backstage and meet the band so right
there they're like they're very very
clever in how they do this stuff now I'm
not saying anything about the band
doesn't do anything right but this
organization knew to go after young
people in these spaces to exploit the
celebrity because they knew I would do
it for them and I was like I don't know
I was like 20 years old yeah yeah well
like that's why the uh Biden talked to
cardi B that's why they talked to the
Rock I mean yeah influence because 40 of
this country is not in the politics but
they'll go do what cardi B says or The
Rock Says that's why they do it because
he's doing all right cardi B's you know
sort of been calling calling it out you
know what I mean have you seen your
stuff yeah
that's right I hit a lid this is seven
dollars
you're going to the Gucci store but the
rock looks broke he looks like he'll
back any candidate for any amount of
money he he's he's he has no tweets no
shame at all he did a tweet and that I
think uh three it was exact on the date
365 day where he you know he was
endorsing them and I responded to him I
said today I want you to remember the
day you you uh recommended the worst
president and worst vice president in
our history I think it was on Instagram
yeah that dude I I you can't tell me he
wasn't paid money to do that yeah he
supported Gavin Newsom when Gavin Newsom
had this whole scandal with the
restaurant he supported any politician
that will just probably give him a
little bit of money yeah yeah that's
what a lot of these that's what a lot of
these celebrities do they're like oh you
want me to support you how much are you
willing to give me yeah that's that's
how it works exactly that is absolutely
selling out this country most
importantly it's like just like John
Cena with his uh you know Mandarin
and that's okay you're allowed to
apologize to China you're allowed to
wear a dress but they're going to ban
you if you've got conservative opinions
why because they want to make sure that
kids only hear one side of the equation
10 years the 10 year old kid
eight-year-old kid right now it's a
eight-year-old kid goes on Tick Tock
Goes to School teachers are grooming
them and all that stuff 10 years from
now that kid's gonna be voting who do
you think they're going to vote for you
yeah unless y'all start speaking up
showing up to skate events this Saturday
10 a.m there you go and just saying look
man
that's what I tell people you don't need
to come out and and wave an American
flag and scream Trump's name out loud
you don't got to put on Q Shaman horns
right and and scream as loud as you can
all you got to do is mind your own
business and just be like where you came
from all you gotta do is mind your own
business and just be like I don't know
about all that that's it
when someone comes to you and says you
know man it's like these trumps that
were so bad like they're all nasty
people just go I don't know about all
that yeah huh interesting no no I don't
know about all that like I don't believe
that's that you don't have to respond to
people that's something that's important
for people to understand I think in
reality you never have to respond right
you might be even in court played the
fifth you know you don't even have to
respond in court legally because we
realize it but ethically there's so many
questions that is are leading you
towards a way of answering you don't
have to respond to that stuff or you
just laugh and say yeah yeah was that
your brother's toilet war cry yeah I
don't know there's something wrong with
him sometimes when you guys were uh
transitioning into politics like what
was that what was your state of mind for
the months before that were you were you
political before
um yeah I just kept it to myself and
when we came out we talked about and I
was like I didn't want to pretty much
alienate half my fan base you know and
that's exactly what we did we came out
it's just at first we tried to come in
neutral just more common sense and it
was still unsubscribed and still you
know saying horrible things about us and
calling the sellouts and Uncle Tom so I
said I just said I just went I just came
out with everything well we did come in
neutral first video that about the kid
we just said no one should be uh
attacked for wearing a shirt expressing
a freshman right whether he's wearing a
body shirt or a trump shirt no one
should ever be attacked for when Obama
shirt or anything and when we post that
top comment Trump supporters I knew it
I'm not subscribing I was like it's not
we lost 15 10 000 followers in like
within an hour yeah supposedly put up on
Instagram yeah it was really it was
really weird
it doesn't it feel like aliens came and
infected their brain and took over their
bodies we took a picture with Trump like
a cardboard cutout yeah and we just put
up and we're just laughing in the in the
photo they thought it was actually
Donald Trump
just how dumb I mean I'm not I'm not
saying they're dumb but people are just
so ignorant yeah it's like
I think that my words I mean I mean that
seriously I mean that figuratively but
it's like the NPC meme is real yeah
these are people who are just like
sitting there with their eyes glazed
over and drill coming out of their mouth
and then they're just like but Donald
Trump is bad and you're like yo it's a
cardboard cutout it's not a real Truck
Yeah but Donald Trump is bad my guy it's
a joke it's not you don't think you
can't you can't their brain is a rock
yeah yeah and uh and they can't even
prove that he's bad they've been taught
that he's bad yeah I know that's the
thing it's like we said this is the
crazy thing about a show like this it's
like you know Luke's uh what are you an
anarchist I guess I'm like moderate
Ian's Wild Card all over the place we're
bringing a lot of fascist liberals
you come out and you say to someone like
I agree with every single one of your
opinions except BLM oh that's it you're
a fraud yeah you're a [ __ ] you're fired
get out you're you're a trump supporter
I mean that whole BLM that was just one
of the biggest frauds of uh of the
decade biggest breaths of our time and a
lot of that money went to Democrat
politicians that was what was the worst
part about it was the misappropriated
funds like people were buying houses one
the woman bought a mansion with that
yeah and what made it worse than living
around white people
with all kinds of police officers yeah
like well-funded police departments yeah
that was a funny thing I remember there
was a BLM protest in Wisconsin we talked
about where
there all these BLM protests are outside
of this guy's house he brandishes a
shotgun so they call the police when the
police come they're all screaming and
cheering police come they're all
screaming and cheering they're like wait
hold on a minute this is a conversation
I'm talking about like uh people that
are susceptible to Cults people you
might want to call them stupid people
with the eyes glazed over they're in so
much pain that they don't even realize
they're in pain but like I think class
Schwab sits around with his buddies at
World economic form has the same
conversation like what do we do with
these people that are just willing to
worship the cult TV like what do we do
with them what's a what's an industrious
like what's a freedom-loving way to deal
with them because otherwise they want to
put them in pods and have them just
create energy yeah typically those
people are very emotional you can get to
the coat strange just by some that makes
them feel sad or happy yeah people that
think that way they're just very easy to
manipulated because they don't have
their emotions in check anybody that way
is like talking to a brick wall yeah
this is why health I think is so
important for me uh and for a lot of
different people because if you don't
have your health right if your gut is
not right your brain can't be operating
prop properly and if your brain's not
working properly you're more emotional
when you're emotion more emotional
you're less logical so I I think first
of all just just having a conversation
about mental health and physical health
I think that's the start and I think
naturally there's a reason there's so
many articles talking about how you know
right Wingers are are more prone to work
out than left Wingers there's a reason
why there's this kind of philosophy of
personal responsibility that's more
prevalent on one side than the other
side so I think a lot of this has to be
done by Leading by example I think we
should never be telling people exactly
what to do I think through empathy
through conversations through listening
to people we could say hey let me try to
help you be the best version of yourself
and when you are you don't need the
government you don't need all the
consumerist products you don't need all
this other bull crap that's superficial
that's made up that's marketed to you
that essentially take away from your
life and the your your kind of uh you
know source that you have here on this
planet you yourself are becoming more of
a self-independent human being that is
uh you know a person that doesn't need
anything and doesn't feed this
yeah um you know but
I believe I believe in everything you
said but
so many people are just so dependent on
other people yeah people are even more
depending on other people not
independent yeah they're easily going to
be swimming it's like it's always gonna
be those people who just depending on
other people and they don't practice
self-accountability and
a lot of those people don't have
families too right so when you have a
family you have a family unit that is
able to depend on each other and help
each other out because not everyone's
going to be 100 personally responsible
and perfect all the time but if you have
a family member to help you out here and
I think this is why there has been such
a concerted effort and such an attack on
the family unit right through culture
through of course online pornography
through of course dating through of
course all the psyapps and psychological
warfare that's happening out there
because then if you're able to make an
individual just by themselves you're
able to make them a victim a lot easier
so so it's not that these people depend
on others is that they depend on
government they want the government to
step in because they have no one else in
their lives to help them or to back them
up so when they get a proposition like
hey the government's going to write you
a two thousand dollar check hey the
government's going to come in here and
give you free health care hey the
government's going to help you uh be
euthanized hey you know people are like
yeah yeah that's give me give me give me
give me give me and then that kind of
that kind of existence where you depend
on others and and suck and be an energy
vampire is an existence that uh people
are trapped in the loop of and and
nudging them and at least having them
concentrate on their physical health and
mental health uh naturally I think would
lead to a solution to the problem yeah
and that will never happen because
Democrats they're going to exploit that
you know they love the facts and they
want to keep people fat let's jump to
the story
from The Daily Mail
it's the most rewarding work we've ever
done Canadian Doctor Who's euthanized
400 people proudly shares how she helped
kill man deemed incapable of choosing
assisted suicide as another physician
says she's helped 300 die did you guys
know that uh euthanasia is now a leading
cause of death in Canada
that's actually legal in Canada legal in
Canada you've been gone it's bad I want
to die and then the bag you got it so we
were just talking about health you were
saying Democrats don't want you to be
healthy no no quite the opposite now
this is Canada so I'm not gonna say it's
it's one for one Democrats but this
establishment liberal machine side of
things is all about hey man walk into
the suicide Booth we'll line you right
up yeah it's objective it's a death cult
it's literally essentially a death cult
and literally essentially literally yeah
yeah I mean I mean I mean Bill Gates
said that there's too many people in
this world and the Canadian Health Care
system is uh overwhelmed so uh what
better solution by state government than
of course offer people to uh off
themselves there was a woman with a
chronic illness she could not get health
care in Canada data because the system
is bunk so they offered killer instead
she does a commercial where she's like
at least I can die with dignity or
whatever and then like a few days later
if the story goes viral because
everyone's freaking out like yo this is
nuts right this old interview gets
released where she's like please I don't
want to die like I need my medical
treatment and it's just like nightmare
scenario death panels like they were
talking about 10 years ago wait a minute
Canada is supposed to have the one of
the best Health Care Systems they got a
death care system now and that's not
even a joke yeah they're they're I mean
look at this thing
told me some scary stories about that
socialized Healthcare they got apparel
it was pretty bad yeah and you know what
I had my first experience with
socialized Healthcare being a veteran I
used to go to the VA that's my first
experience having socialized medicine
that service I got at the VA was
horrible what was it like I I could not
walk I was in so much better my back
yeah
um I I had some family come direct me to
the hospital and they was throwing me
all over the place
throw me just like like a wrap you
couldn't move and I was in pain and they
had the ugliest attitude I thought I was
gonna die they were so rude and so
Unapologetic and the way they was
throwing me wet around and I was in so
much pain
and that's the last time I ever went to
the VA were you telling them while they
were doing it like hey oh they know
exactly how much pain I couldn't walk I
couldn't even stand so I hadn't walked
in like two days I hurt my back and had
a sciatic nerve issue or something like
that so and when I was in the hospital
man I was so scared to death I told my
wife don't leave me here don't leave me
here they gave me two shots and I asked
and some medication I got the hell out
of that and I never went back the
government has no incentive to provide a
good product because they have the
Monopoly exactly and and this is why you
know socialized Health Care is leading
to essentially the government saying oh
you can't get a Mobility Scooter why
don't you just kill yourself which is
absolutely happening right now in Canada
which is absolutely because I'm just a
number you're just a number so it says
incapable of um uh wanting to say that
they want suicide what do they mean by
incapable but they can't talk or no he
didn't he he did not have a serious
illness or the capacity to make informed
decisions about his own health it was he
unconscious or it's like someone who's
like yeah I got a mental illness and
they're like yeah we're gonna kill him
anyway wow yo that's like crazy I'm
sorry dude I hate to go full God wins
love but that's Nazi level stuff yeah
that's enough where they were like
people who are you know invalid they
would say would they would they would
execute euthanize if you if you've got a
death if you got a decision you're going
to likely they should be there to ease
your pain but if you're not able to ask
for Youth and being euthanized or not
it's just sick man yeah the first
comment to this story is uh that they're
giving Joseph Mengele a run for his
money and uh they're not wrong yeah
they're absolutely not wrong but this is
this is the first layer of it what's
what's the step two what's the step
three
um well the Nazis did skip the first
level they just went and executed them
like they weren't asking do you want to
do it them so at least they're getting
the train car and then the next thing
you knew you were in a death camp yeah
yeah
Dr Kevorkian he was like those were
terminally ill people and they wanted to
die right people who were really old and
they were like I can't do this anymore
every day hurts right he's like I'm
gonna ease your suffering for you you
know I think about that because what do
you do when you see like a deer hit by a
car and its legs are broken yeah well
it's like you know look we're not gonna
leave it here just to wheeze out and
suffer and die you put out of its misery
right it's an animal though not a person
yeah so I think I think I'm not sure if
it was Sheamus we talked about with this
but that's basically what he said like a
human you try and save no matter what
animals we don't you know it's like we
gotta get suffering we'll put it out of
its misery my view is like if you're if
you're past a certain age if you're
terminal if you've got a time limit then
maybe it's okay to say you know we
figure out a way to give you dignity but
the problem with it is the reason why I
ultimately end up leaning away I think
it was Sheamus said this is that you
open the door the next thing you know
they're going to find the justifications
yeah oh this 15 year old kid oh but
doctor said the doctor's gonna come out
and be like
I think he's got two months to live it's
kind of like a gun argument too you ban
rifles then they're going to come before
you handguns you can't well doing it
kind of already like if you want life
support and you unresponsive they want
the family yes if your brain did though
yeah yeah wow but some peoples came back
how do we even know someone's brain does
is the challenge right yeah so it's like
the doctor might what we're really
saying is like do you trust the doctor
and so you're I don't trust any doctor
after this who think about how scary
that must be if you're if you're if
you're like they call it locked in
syndrome or whatever like you move your
eyes but you can't move your body right
and the doctors shine in the light and
you're moving and the doctor goes look
up for yes and you look up and he's like
look down for now and you look down I
think it's a stimuli I I don't think
it's actually in there and you're like
Twilight Zone yeah but this has happened
and then the doctor's like I recommend
pulling the plug and and people like
you're screaming in your mind yeah there
there have been many I mean look there's
a lot of people on the planet a lot of
people live of course there are stories
like this it's not it's not you know
magical that it happened people who are
paralyzed and the doctors think they're
not there and then they come to later
like I could hear everything did you see
that story about the guy in a coma for
like 15 years of his life and they made
him watch Barney every day
remembered it he was he was conscious
during it but he couldn't tell them
please turn it off
sorry that's horrible but he's he's
doing well now now I hated Barney when I
was a kid though I did too I thought
that was the only the only one I hate it
I got so I was like what is this bull
crap yeah
15 years of being forced to watch Barney
every single day or waking up during
surgery from anesthesia I wake up from
surgery give me that any day right now
we didn't get knocked back out for 15
years of Bonnie the dinosaurs it was he
was in for 12 years this one guy 12 year
coma and they were playing Barney it's
like God reruns at least play reruns of
like the A-Team or something right yeah
it's not like they was trying to kill
him
or maybe they're trying to get him to
get up to change the channel yeah it
felt like just leave it on and
eventually he'll have to wake up from
this he's going for the remote he grabs
it yeah his name if anyone wants to look
at him is Martin Pistorius is his name
Amazing Story oh that's so that's so
brutal I think yeah I think they were
trying to kill him trying to give him a
heart attack yeah yeah just his blood
pressure they're like they're in the
room and they're taking his vitals
Barney turns on and then they're like
wait something's happening his blood
pressure is rising what are you doing I
don't know I was tapping his hand and it
was like Barney's saying I love you the
guy inside the coma he was smug he was
patronizing he Barney was not a good
person okay he was not a lot of people
have it twisted on him and his defense
he was dinosaur but now imagine you see
they were grooming kids to like
dinosaurs because now if a dinosaur shut
up it's gonna eat somebody and the kid's
not he's being tricked it's like it's
like when the cat gives the rat
toxoplasmosis yeah and the rat doesn't
fear the cat anymore and the cat eats it
yes there you go that's exactly that's
exactly it's some big hippo propaganda
like hippos are the most nasty like
dangerous animals on Earth yeah they are
but I was a Hungry Hungry Hippo was like
the cutest yeah more videos them coming
at you like you ever see those big
mouths oh man bro have you ever seen
them fight no you don't want that smoke
Dude tell me right now you don't want
that at all yeah
hippo no you don't even get our own
characters to pack up they run away
every time I remember Barney man when it
came out it was I was just like getting
out of middle school or high school or
something so I was just like ebbing out
of that kind of show but my younger
brother would watch it and it was like
the weirdest like disgusting saddest
like Make It Stop kind of met my mindset
it was it like brainwashing was that
like they were singing them these weird
Rhymes it was so annoying I just think
it was annoying I I'm not sure there's
anything
hey I don't know man how about this I
remember I was uh I had my little boy
and I was in the living room right and I
heard some I thought it was a gay guy on
TV I said who the hell is gay guy on the
team I can hear him from the living room
I went in on his SpongeBob SquarePants I
was like what the hell is this yeah I
love SpongeBob yeah yeah this movie see
came out loved I was like growing the
door like yeah
but he gives he gives his memes like the
one where SpongeBob and Patrick burn
everything down and then say we saved
the city yeah yeah right right it's like
you slide the Democrat D on it and
you're like there yeah yeah that's what
that's what it is I love that character
in it first movie came out Dennis yeah
oh yeah I love Dennis I love that
SpongeBob movie times so weird I love it
yeah yeah that's good I mean there used
to be some good kids shows they were
always adult jokes in them that were
hidden subtly you know I love the old
Tom and Jerry cartoons yeah that's funny
Yosemite Sam he was an [ __ ] you know
what's a crazy fact is that people think
Nimrod means idiot but it was because
Bugs Bunny called Elmer Fudd Nimrod
right right sarcastically referring to
him as the great hunter uh-huh so he was
like Hey Nimrod yeah and then people who
didn't know anything about I thought I'm
an idiot or something exactly because
because people watching Bugs Bunny
didn't understand the joke Nimrod is the
great hunter right Elmer fudd's not oh
so we called him Nimrod and then
everyone assumed he was calling him an
idiot
Nim Mirage yeah they canceled all those
cartoons because they said it was
teaching violence to kids oh man yeah
and then they started making video games
they call it walking simulators have you
heard about this this has been for a
while now
video games and movies are all violent
right you're like watch watch any you
know I was watching uh the the trailer
the they did some kind of like live
stream for the new Harry Potter video
game and it's like it's Harry Potter it
says Millennial woke as they come the
kids love this stuff
and then it's like he goes and now for
combat and then it shows some dude like
levitating a guy slicing him up and
slanting them into walls and I was just
like you know this combat's a part of
like how we play games yeah right but a
lot of woke people want to remove that
element and make games about like
holding hands singing like planting
flowers
no hey man look look you know there
there's some there's some games what's
that game that ever plays we walk on the
island you know what I'm talking about
Minecraft no my but Minecraft's got some
violence because you're like hidden
cactuses or something yeah those weird
little monsters what's those creepers
trying to ruin your houses no but
there's a game there's a game where
you're on like an island with a bunch of
animal people
you know are people people can tell me
what that game is in the chat you know
what I'm talking about I don't know the
animal people yeah you know what I'm
talking about animal people man and uh
Harvest Moon Harvest Moon
yeah yeah and like you what do you do
like you plant a garden or something
yeah you just like you like live a life
you mean furries are you talking about
furries I don't know about that this
room with stardew Valley yeah that's one
of the new ones that's the new Harvest
Moon yeah oh I see there you go that's
what I'm saying I was saying like not
every game is violent you know but
they're trying to take violence out of
games and it's like look you play a game
it's fine it's fine now what they're
doing is they're trying to make Grand
Theft Auto woke by making the main
character a female so it's like so if
you want to bang hookers and shoot
people you can be a woman when you do it
now dude that's wokeness I guess you
know what game is super racist and
violent chess
it's the blacks versus the ones yeah the
whites are the aggressors
and they're all killing each other
it's essentially a good point gotta we
gotta change the color of Chester like
uh uh like blue and light blue damn well
better because it really indicates like
Middle Eastern Conference
you changed it to Red the blue is then
it's the Blues versus the Crips no no
you do blue and light blue that way
everybody's blue but you can tell them
apart right right or you just do numbers
like the ones and the twos no no no no
one side is the a side and the side is
the one side that way no one's beneath
each other and no one's a different
color you got a board full of all the
same color pieces
woke chest man it's crazy all right
let's jump into this story man because
this this video is going viral and I'm
sure everybody's seen it Canadian TV
reporter suffers medical emergency live
on air telling hosts she's not feeling
well and slurs words before Eerie Blank
Stare let me let me see if we can play
this video
oh let me fix the I always I always do
this with the audio because I'm like
playing music this is hard to watch so I
haven't seen guys you haven't seen this
one I haven't seen it it's a little hard
to watch so which one you know okay
oh it's so quiet
yeah it's still on the it's still on
this it's coming through the mics oh is
that it what yeah it's not it's not no I
assume it should be like no I changed it
it's not the right one oh there was a uh
is that the right one it's just that
it's super low audio in chess you don't
kill pieces you capture them you make
them slavery
don't kill them to sleep
let's play this from boosting it up week
before the third anniversary
well people we spoke with say they were
happy that something is being done but
this is something that they've been
asking for since day one so for them
this is about a thousand days too late
now nevermind I'm looking at uh through
the day families are pushing feds to
pushing the feds to
sorry Airman I'm
I'm not feeling very well right now and
I'm about just okay well come back to me
right now and we'll make sure that
Jessica you are doing okay thank you we
will oh dude look at that last part
again watch watch how she like her eyes
just zoom out now we make sure right
there dude yeah right through here thank
you we will and then she's like dude she
fell yeah they cut away from her she she
hit the ground
now everybody's everybody's got their
theories of course this young woman uh
on TV look something like that stuff
like this has happened before so I don't
wanna I don't want to over hype this or
downplay it I just want to be like I
don't know I know what it is you know
absolutely I think it's very clear that
evidence is 100 there that this was
absolutely climate change that is
responsible for them it is Canada and
the weather has been really hot lately
there yeah and it makes sense also like
I think everyone at the equator is
already dead I think there's a reason
there's a migrant crisis here that the
so media is not telling us and uh I you
gotta trust the science
yeah yeah actually look I think you're
right yeah look at the story from Vice
scientists studying temperature at which
humans spontaneously die with increasing
urgency what wet bulb conditions are
when heat and humidity can cause
otherwise healthy humans to overheat and
die they're happening more often than
ever oh that explains it she's wearing a
thick coat I know it's cold out but the
humidity is building up she's having a
wet bulb inside of her thing you know
and her brain just starts boiling in her
head and then she's like oh then she
goes down that's crazy is this something
you would expect to see on the Babylon b
or something and that's not the first
article there's any articles like this
making the same kind of argument that
there has been a slight change in
temperatures and therefore this is
causing people to drop dead uh suddenly
you know what yeah they've just been
dropping dead for years but I think it's
more common now right it's more common
you see look at it look at the sports it
is for sure look at this article right
here like August 2022. rise in heart
disease may be explained by extreme
weather conditions that's look it's
climate change so it's not a mother
clock your arteries look at look at this
look at this it says it's not clear why
temperature shifts correlate with more
heart attacks then why are you reporting
it
that's a good question see this is this
is proof that people will believe
anything and Democrats exploit this all
the time exactly the the exploit naive
people no no I figured it out if we're
if we're playing the correlation game I
got a lot of things correlates uh heart
attacks are linked with Joe Biden
draining the petroleum reserves you know
what it must be when Biden started
offloading all of our petroleum reserves
people started getting real bad anxiety
causing heart attacks yeah even in 15
year olds yeah those 15 year olds on the
soccer field they're like
if we're gonna play this game of
correlate correlation in there like you
see the one where they said unvaccinated
are more likely to get in car accidents
yeah
are they telling us to follow the signs
which if they're falling inside just
because we have a causation doesn't mean
that's actually what's causing it yeah
yeah it just because you have a
correlation doesn't mean conversation
what else is going on this past year
that would be fun to correlate into all
these people having heart attacks racism
clearly you know the rise of racism
y'all seen the fat black women say
they're fat because of white people yeah
yeah so obesity too is caused by racism
caused by racism no no so what's another
major thing that happened in this uh in
this past year like big news advantage
in the Middle East that probably oh oh
dude I mean a lot of heart attacks are
probably caused by Joe Biden's botched
Afghanistan withdrawal hands down
there's a lot of uh there's a lot of GMO
mosquitoes too they just started
vaccinating the bees that's going to
work out really well Bill Gates is doing
really a cool stuff yeah
anxiety oh hey hey shout out uh New York
Times if you're listening I got a good
one for you say write an article that
says anxiety over World War III because
of Putin's invasion is causing heart
attacks boom and now what you do is when
some like says 17 year old kid has
collapse on the field again because we
have hundreds of these stories you just
be like you know we talked to his
parents and yes they talk like you ask
the parents have you ever talked about
Russia you did boom there it is now we
have evidence yeah now you can say we
asked the parents if they'd ever spoken
about Russia they said yes their kids
had heart attack does it bother you to
think that we might go to World War III
if they say yes then you know that's
indicates stress not so much as the
heart attack yeah you know what it's
crazy growing up when I was in the
military there was a bunch of these
athletes having heart attacks on the
fields and they was able to link it
within like maybe a couple of months
that it was linked to a pre-workout it
had some type of caffeine that was
linked to wow yeah similar to it it's
like method yeah yeah and they were able
to get rid of it but we've got all these
people dropping their need and they're
trying to say it's because uh climate
change yeah do you think they would
locate the the car yes yeah I mean these
are scientists y'all remember when Kobe
first broke they could name it to the
second to who was dying in India who was
dying in Texas who was down in Florida
and it's like a night it was like a
voting map yeah election night remember
when those videos from China were coming
out of people dropping dead suddenly
right at the beginning of covet right
that was talked about that was on the
media this really isn't remember that
nurse they got that vaccination
vaccinated live and she just passes out
yeah I was like I really ain't taking
that [ __ ]
you know
I think I think the problem we're having
is that as the media lies more and more
as we expose more and more the media
lies people will literally either
believe or not believe anything yeah
you've got a tribal element of it where
you've got people on the left who are
like I'm gonna believe whatever the
media says no matter what and even push
the lies because they're an occult then
you got people on the other side who are
just like don't care I'm not going to
believe it that's a problem either way
you cut it yeah yeah like proper
thinking on both sides but so I guess
what I'm thinking of is that Yuri besman
oven if you guys ever see it oh yeah the
Russian he's like the former Soviet guys
explain how to destroy a country he's
saying make sure no one knows what's
true and quite literally us that we're
trapped in it right right we're out
outside outright being like this story
is the you're more likely to get in a
car accident because you didn't get
vaccinated that's probably because you
live in the middle of nowhere and
probably because you don't drive that
often yeah yeah you know what um you
know what the cause of all the of our
problems I'm trying it backwards you're
more likely to drive than you are if
you're in a city yeah um the reason why
we're having so many problems in this
country it's not because of these
politicians if the media did that job
like they supposed to do that's why we
have the First Amendment to keep our
politicians accountable when you are in
a communist country you don't have a
media but that's why we have the first
amendment in this country and not
because our media won't do the right
thing hold both sides accountable that's
why we're in the position we're in yeah
it's like what's the point in having the
media if you're not gonna you're just
gonna you know stand up for the left or
you're just gonna stand up for the right
there's a lot more of that going on on
the left but yeah stuff like this this
is not journalism and they're grossly
negligent about the kid what was the the
pro-life um school that was going to do
a pro-life March at the Capitol and that
yeah Nick said man it was like yeah Nick
salmon yeah yeah yeah
they end up having to pay that guy like
how much like hundreds of millions of
dollars but they they ran that store
because they gotta paint Trump
supporters as like these evil racist
people and that's why you got people
dude they're pod people yeah you see
that you said thing of uh Jimmy Fallon
singing about xbb 1.5 wow oh my God yeah
he's a pod person man pot people can't
get humor it's like an alien coming here
like in The Matrix when uh that guy is
like everything tastes like chicken
because the robots don't know what
things taste like right yeah the pod
people don't know how to do jokes so
they're like doing these really
off-putting facsimiles of humor it
doesn't work or Klaus Schwab is like
dance now and he's like okay
poor guy I mean he could see the soul
just being sucked out of his life in
existence on this Earth X1 BB one point
my poor guy I mean can you imagine can
you imagine the human suffering that's
how low you have to think of yourself to
be such a stooge
backstage yeah seriously
Stephen Colbert did it like what a
couple years ago the vaccine yeah he did
he did a vaccine dance he actually did a
whole bunch yeah yeah he did a bunch of
it was a it's a black dating app what
was the name of that dating app oh it
came with their vaccine you remember it
was like a rap song it was ratchet and
he was [ __ ] oh my God
what about that it was a black dating
app just for black people yeah so you
already know this rap song is gonna be
ratcheted [ __ ] and they're rapping about
getting vaccinated yeah it was and then
the lead singer was a trans yeah and I'm
not sure which way it was a trans girl
physical was it backs that ass up
something like that yeah I think that I
think I think I saw that yeah and Max
that ass up I was like look at that like
is this really how y'all see black
people [ __ ] this is how you're gonna
approach them and Market them a vaccine
is this vaccine thing up yeah yeah
there's a juvenile is that juvenile yes
that was juvenile too yeah my goodness
wow there's a spin-off for his song yeah
and everybody's coming it's like is that
a dude oh he remixed Back That Thing You
yeah that thing up maybe not to miss
Back That Thing Up yeah it was so
remarkably bad do you guys uh you can
play it you guys see this story uh well
I was gonna bring this one up the
basketball player who uh who collapsed
on the court I didn't hear about that
yeah yeah this one this one also went
vile take a look we'll play this oh wow
I didn't see this wait I just want to
make sure the volume is not too loud
it's college right this is uh this is
college right here look at this dude
number three right there boom watch this
he starts grabbing his chest then slowly
goes down to the ground players from
both teams visibly upset after watching
take a look
that wasn't because they know it wasn't
basketball that caused it that wasn't
commercial Cardis no yeah you know when
that when uh nothing hit him that
football player got tackled yeah you
know so I I I've asked a medical
professional and they said well that one
could be like and this is somebody who's
like complaining about the vaccines we
have we have a you know Medical
Professional we know but you know what's
crazy it's never happened before I watch
football
in football perhaps yeah in football
yeah so it's like it was the guy in the
50s he had a blood clot but he had a
blood clot and then he like died in the
field in the 70s 71 71 yeah something
like that so right at the end of the
game too
it could be I'm not going to sit here
and pretend it is you know I mean like
the media is going to come out and be
like always you know it's commercial
Cardis and better parents got to watch
it for their kids and it's like if that
was that was like winning the lottery
yeah exactly that's what about what all
the chances of that happen it happens in
baseball because a hard projectile is
projectile is thrown at like 30 to 50
miles an hour or whatever hits a kid
right above the heart and then stuns
their heart yeah but this guy you have
pads to come down like this yeah that's
like well look man this guy just fell
down for no reason yeah yeah and he got
it up quick and then he fail us like
this one and then they they brought him
the bench and they're sending him to a
Cardiologist so he just he just went
down my uh my uh guy that travels with
us does shows he got the backs because
he had to for work so he didn't have no
choice and he was on stage he opens for
us remember time he had an episode he
had an episode up on stage where his
chest started hurting really bad and he
got pale and he's a black guy and he
wasn't feeling good he he had to cut his
set and call us out sooner and he's like
dude I don't know why he said man my
chest was just like it was hurting and I
couldn't breathe out short of breath
that's like are you fine nice like yeah
I'm fine but he said I don't know if
they'll happen I think I just
hyperventilated
everybody has a choice yeah that choice
might be you get to be homeless and live
in the woods and you might starve to
death like you know certainly it's
coercive elements but you had you have a
choice I think for you know look I I
don't know what's causing any of this
and I'm not gonna pretend to know I'm
gonna say talk to a doctor but I'm gonna
tell you if you feel a certain way about
what's going on you better make you
better make the choice you think is
going to keep you alive yeah I mean I I
bought a car like about a year ago and I
was doing my paperwork with the finance
guy and he shared a story with me about
his daughter
he's like this is right when the uh you
know the uh the Alki came out the fact I
actually came out and he said his
daughter wants to travel and go to
Europe but because of covety she
couldn't do it but not because the
vaccine was out you can go travel in
Europe and go to all these great
placements you have to be vaccinated so
she got vaccinated and two weeks before
she took off the uh to go on her trip
she dropped dead of a blood clot wow
she's in her early 20s
so he told me he's like dude if you if
if you're healthy he's like dude I
wouldn't that's what he told me
personally and well so I I I had
something I talked to a doctor so like I
I I did not get the vaccine right I
talked to a doctor and they said this
was this was back before uh this was
around the time when they were like we
don't know how many we got and they were
like you're young you're you're not in
the risk factor right you exercise let
someone else get it you're you're not
the person for us like someone who's 70
needs this when I got sick we went to
the doctor you know everybody knows that
story but uh I talked to a doctor and
that's what they told me I think for a
lot of people they got mad because they
went to their doctors and the doctors
were like don't know don't care just do
it or a lot of people like pulled up at
7-Eleven parking lots right my thing was
like look
ask your doctor questions about the news
and what's going on ask them like hey
man you know I heard this story if they
can if they can properly inform you and
they and you trust them then take your
doctor's advice but but there's a lot of
people who are complaining because their
doctors don't seem to know what's going
on and I'm like that's like hiring a
plumber it doesn't fix a toilet yeah you
know what I mean like find a doctor who
knows what's going on and get some good
medical advice I think they have a
financial incentive to recommend this
shot too and that's a conflict of
interest not just that but like opiates
and any drug right that's a big problem
too yeah yeah we definitely learned a
lot through the opioid epidemic but just
the bigger picture being that doctors
recommend drugs because pharmaceutical
companies make money off of it they send
them free samples I hurt my knee when I
was a kid skating and the doctor handed
me like five like bundles of steroid
samples like here you need this for an
anti-inflammatory and I was just like
what is this yeah so how do you fix that
though with doctors well I I understand
that I think you make people understand
that doctors could be as easily bought
off as politicians right
um and and I think you make people
prioritize their own health and I think
at the you know what the best kind of
medical advice I could give anybody is
to do what is right for them and every
individual is unique everyone's
different but we also have to realize
that there is a war on your health
there's a lot of very powerful people
that are interested in making you fat
and making you sad and making you
infertile and a lot of this war is waged
through our food so I think uh just just
living as an example I think educating
people and telling people as much as we
can this is what I do this is what I
focus on a lot especially with my
members area oops sorry there I remember
area specifically focusing and talking
about a lot of these issues on a
one-on-one kind of personal basis and
when I go to the doctor I travel a lot
and I see a lot of different doctors out
there and I and I always kind of ask and
I'm like hey you
you did you and you know based on that
conversation or based off him even uh or
her asking me hey what's your diet
what's your stress levels uh how's your
sleep schedule uh what are you are you
doing any physical exercise if the
doctor's asking me that then I know the
doctor's actually incentivized to uh
helping me and and taking care of me
otherwise they're just like here take
these pills automatically that's a red
flag and that should be a red flag for a
lot of people you know what I found most
alarming about the pandemic when they
start recommending this the uh the the
shot even if you had already contracted
the virus yeah
really weird yeah yeah because like who
gets chickenpox and then go gets the
chickenpox vaccine well I think you're
not supposed to I'm not the doctor yeah
from what I'm told is you get a vaccine
to help your body kick up an immune
response so that you don't get really
sick from the thing if you already got
sick from the thing don't get the
vaccine because your body's already
kicked up the immune response that's
what I'm told that's what a lot of
doctors were saying and then they were
the ones that were censored they're the
ones that were kicked out uh there's uh
two famous doctors from California came
out and and did a video specifically
about this that video has taken off of
YouTube what I did like is you're good
oh now when I called the doctor they
said explicitly you cannot get the
vaccine if you've had covid you have to
wait they said you had to wait like a
month or two or something like that it's
crazy people that got it got the vaccine
and the damn boost yeah and it's like Dr
Falcon was pushing that idea it's like
no you uh because they wasn't they
didn't they hadn't determined yet how
long your immunity was up after getting
covered when he's been doing this for
decades he has a good idea that your
immunity just just doesn't run out in a
year we give blood like every what what
four months six months and six months
two years that since I got coveted I
still hadn't I still had the antibodies
from covet yeah and I caught it twice
the second time was nothing that first
time was rough the president the first
time we got it it was the worst thing I
ever experienced oh yeah and my feet
turned blue oh wow my feet turned blue
yeah and me and Kevin was calling each
other every hour every couple I say
making you still breathe or you die
trying to filter that garbage out of
your body but my feet turned blue and I
was like man this is because I've had
the fluid but this that covet it was
that's the crazy thing too and I kept
hearing people say like oh it's like the
flu and I'm like not for me dude
y'all remember the Republican they say
it's just a flu it's just a bad thing
No No so at first I was like
other people got sick before me and then
I'm all like I'm not gonna get sick you
know I'm eating I'm eating right and I'm
I'm exercising and then a day or two
later I'm like I'm feeling sick it's not
so bad I'll work and then it worked the
next day I'm like wow I feel really sick
I don't think I can work today I'm gonna
have to lay down right right the next
day it was so bad I was shaking yeah I
actually I called local hospital and
they said what do you want us to do it's
a virus and I was like is there a
protocol is there like IV fluids or what
are like no stay home good luck yeah
later that night I was so bad that I was
like
I'm not going to wait around to find out
that I'm gonna I'm going to the hospital
or something I don't want to you know
figure out what's going to be but I was
I was breathing heavy so I I know Joe
talked a lot about it on his show about
right his treatment yeah and I was like
bro I got it bad I'm feeling like death
what's up and then he was just I told
him like I called the hospital they said
nothing he's like no no call like a
private practice tell them what you're
experiencing they can give you something
anything like here's the thing even if
you're sick they can give you IV fluids
because that'll that'll help you you're
dehydrated right like these doctors will
help you out so the challenge is a lot
of these treatments like monoclonal
antibodies is 2 500 per per treatment oh
wow so sure enough we're we're lucky
enough to be able to have this uh taken
care of right and uh we actually got
everybody the treatment but like
overnight I was better yeah it was crazy
you know it's uh we're like um when I
was wasn't feeling well my wife was real
concerned she was like a big time cover
space right so she sent me down to the
clinic to find out within 24 hours the
rapid response
so
I get the rapid response Destiny call
you back and um and I called back and I
called at least you're you have covered
and it's funny I was one of those guys
just the flu was just the flu so she
told me that I had constantly oh man I'm
gonna freaking die that was like my
first response yeah yeah hey Echo Health
Alliance spent a lot of your tax dollars
uh weaponizing a virus and they did a
good job at it guys we got we got huge
breaking news that's what Trump say
nothing funny Diamond of diamond and
silk has died what so we have Michael
Morrison it's reposting a truth from
Trump really bad news Republicans and
frankly all Americans are beautiful
Diamond of diamond and silk has just
passed away at her home in the state she
loves so much North Carolina silk was
with her all the way and at her passing
there was no no better team anywhere
anytime Diamond's death was totally
unexpected probably your big Precious
Heart just plain gave out rest in peace
our magnificent Diamond you'll be
greatly missed and we have this from the
official diamond and silk Twitter
account right here
they say the world just lost a true
angel warrior Patriot for Freedom love
and Humanity please respect the privacy
of Diamond's family Memorial ceremony
TBA contributions towards preserving
diamonds Legacy error only being
accepted the following link
man that's crazy this just happened they
posted this two minutes ago so somebody
somebody posted in the Super Chat
um that diamond it took it passed away I
immediately went to fact check this is
about five minutes ago I saw the post
from the office of Mike couldn't get up
truth social because truth social blocks
you from viewing posts unless you like
are logged in or whatever uh and then
diamond and Silk's official kind of just
posted it so rest in peace man big
bummer sad to hear it yeah yeah
I I didn't know her I didn't know
anything about them this first I've
heard of them personalities what are
their what are their what are they known
for sport and Trump I guess yeah
whenever you're a black woman and you
support Trump openly I mean yeah it's
your celebrity
overnight because you don't see it as we
like unicorns so whenever a black person
supports a Republican president yeah
amazing yeah yeah I was gonna say Pariah
I mean you probably you guys probably
get attacked like crazy like them yeah
as soon as you guys came out like you
mentioned you lost fans yeah it's like I
don't know it's just being black you're
like supposed to be Democrats like
and isn't that weird that it's like the
people claim to be fighting for racism
are perpetuating exactly what they plan
to be fighting against that's because
Joe Biden picks his vice president
because she's black that's why they
picked the jokes because she black
it's just great politicians you know
what I mean but where where yeah that
pisses off racist white people or racist
people get pissed off if someone of
another race
puts someone of their race in because
they feel like they're getting undercut
just makes more animosity exactly
they call us token blacks but they do it
all the time but it's okay yeah it's
like it's a double stand oh I'm gonna
pick a black one oh I'm gonna pick this
because she's black I mean ain't they
talking black you didn't get before them
to them for their qualification but they
call us token negro yeah because yeah it
feels so obvious that yeah putting
someone in a position because of their
color it's obvious right racist right
it's obvious right but the issue is that
he proclaimed it is that he's like I
promised I would have a you know woman
of color as my VP and it's like if he
just picked Kamala Harris people would
be like you think he did that as a
virtue signal they wouldn't be saying
out right like we know he did it because
he's racist it's for the black book
though that's why he's doing that's why
he's got to say it that's why the
Supreme Court he he appointed she's not
even a judge she doesn't even know what
a woman is she's not crazy yeah yeah
that girl's name I don't know you guys
know the woman's name the new Supreme
Court Justice
he's the black woman that doesn't know
what a woman is but I'll tell you one of
the most offensive things about is
Kareem Jean-Pierre is his press
secretary is just he's really bad at her
job she's horrible imagine she's going
to be because she has to laugh for too
bad so yeah great press secretary but no
she's home she's horrible Jen's sake you
knew she was lying but she was pretty
good she know how to play the game yeah
and then so it's like uh you're really
frustrated you're like come on she
doesn't have that it's really good off
the cuff yeah but um if she doesn't have
that paperwork in front of the root off
of the other girl that new girl she's
blind she she's done she wouldn't have
nothing to say yeah because she can't
think for herself it's all she's
actually a token yeah it's like ESG
stuff but in government I mean it's all
the same I guess yeah that's the
weirdest thing like what's what's the
United States going to look like when
they're like okay we got rid of anybody
capable of doing the job but everybody
who's here looks like a rainbow yeah
it's like that dude still in suitcases
why did he get his dog
suitcases right that's so weird too like
what was up with that you know anything
people were saying that he would steal
women's clothing and then get off on
wearing it in public
[Laughter]
it makes sense though like it
makes it I call him an honest politician
because like what he was doing is just a
small amount of what all the other
politicians are doing on such a bigger
level so at least he did it to people's
you know sort of face sort of kind of
not really but kind of stealing the
luggage and walking away and then lying
about it is the funniest thing it's like
bro you're on campus
baggage when you flew why are you
grabbing people's suitcases like I think
a lot of people lose their luggage all
the time right this is and and we never
find it
how much was that bag he stole it was
like an expensive design so they
investigated that yeah yeah what is it
to me is it the company to me something
like that super expensive bags you ever
see that oh yeah oh yeah like you get a
little carry-on bags like a thousand
dollars yeah oh yeah yeah so he grabbed
the wrong bag man yeah he could have
grabbed that Walmart twenty dollar bag
and people would have been like that's
why he grabbed it that's right yeah he's
thinking like ooh there's gonna be a
nice dress in here I can wear yeah good
news from earlier Demar Hamlin's
released from the hospital we were
talking earlier about athletes falling
down and he had did they say why like
they say what he had or what happened
didn't say one week after cardiac arrest
he's gave a statement he's headed home
to Buffalo with a lot of love in my
heart on my heart good for you I hope he
makes a full recovery of course but do
you think the truth will ever come out
well I think actually happened the
healthier he is the more likely the
truth will come out you think so he's
the guy he's the spokesman for what
happened to him you know he seems like a
good guy he had a great charity going
and I think if something I think he
would speak the crew I'm hoping you
would a regardless but how many of these
so you know I talked about a friend of
mine who uh he he lost control of his
hands and his legs after he got the
vaccine and the doctors the doctors told
them that's what it was yeah right yeah
and and like yeah I'm not telling you
what is or isn't I'm saying like this
has literally happened okay same thing
talk to your doctor about what makes
sense for you the doctors came out later
and said it was a vitamin deficiency
that's an important point of the story
so the issue is
what are you allowed or supposed to
think or how are you supposed to know
when you get conflicting stories because
here's my issue obviously there's a lot
of people come out and they want to
blame the vaccine and I'm like yo it's
really hard when I'm sitting in a room
reading stories and we're all at our
computers trying to figure out what's
going on the one thing I can say is sure
a lot of stories about people collapsing
on Sports Fields And while running and
doing all these things and there's
there's you know let's say hypotheses
and theories about what's going on but
we're not getting any official work done
on on investigating red flag right there
had they made it official that the
vaccine coaches blood clots
yeah you did I talked about it because
it was uh
here's what they said AstraZeneca and
Jonathan Johnson did get flagged for a
rare side effect of blood clots right
but the Pfizer uh Pfizer bioentec one
they said was they the study showed
strong signals of blood clots but not
evidence of causation just correlation
now here's a funny thing
they do the climate change thing for
people you know having heart attacks and
it's just a correlation yeah yeah you
guys no hey hey that was just a
correlation yeah so you know the best
thing anyone can say is and I mean this
sincerely we don't know for sure
just to make sure your doctor is up to
date on all of this information if your
doctor can't answer your questions find
one who can it's that simple because
because the media is going to censor
everything YouTube's got their rules
there's different varying opinions all
that matters in my in my view is you
have a doctor who knows what they're
talking about and then you get sound
medical advice yeah that happened to my
assistant law as well if you couldn't
she couldn't walk she lost all that Eric
Clapton yeah you know Eric Clapton is
the top player yeah and he's like I
can't use my hands what happened and so
you know one thing I think too is if you
give 400 million doses of a vaccine yeah
and it's got like a fraction like you
know 0.1.01 side effect you're going to
see a thousand several thousand stories
right and it might freak you out right
but the real issue might be that just
gave out 400 million doses you know what
I mean right so that's why I'm like look
man I don't want to be biased one way or
the other but obviously I think people
need to get sound medical advice from a
guy who knows all about this yeah but
you don't want to you know you don't
want to go to a doctor and he's just
like oh I don't know anything about this
but here's my advice no no go to doctor
who can be like here's the studies we
saw here's here's my opinion on them and
here's my recommendation for you didn't
do it in long-term studies though they
test dummy like yeah beans of people and
they tested no no but when they tested
it whenever someone got hurt they just
kicked them out of the trial right so
that data was skewed and we're trusting
the data that was given given by them
done by them that they're that they have
no liability for that they make a profit
off of this product while the government
is not uh Connecting the Dots here or
investigating any of this that just
thinks not just that they're not
investigating it it's that President
Biden seven hours ago tweeted out
everyone six months and up should get
their updated call feeding vaccine
coveted vaccine like why is a non-doctor
telling people to get covered vaccines
six months old this is what bothers me
about the whole thing is that I can sit
here all day and be like find a doctor
who's right for you and Joe Biden
doesn't have to right and these
celebrities don't have to and The Rock
doesn't have to right these other big
YouTubers don't have to and I'm like
wait wait man how is it that if you say
something like I'm not a doctor but my
recommendation is not to take this
medication it's like oh we're gonna ban
you but this guy who's not a doctor is
saying pull into a 7-Eleven parking lot
let a stranger inject you that's the
craziest thing to me no my right I got
into it I talk about the story I got
into it on Twitter because Casey neistat
he's a cool dude he said you know go get
the vaccine or whatever and I responded
with like go talk to a doctor and figure
out exactly yeah and then the response I
got from him was like he's like that's
weird I did I just drove into a park
into a parking lot and got it through
the window and I was like yo
he also he also said vote for Hillary
Clinton and he did work for CNN so he
doesn't have the best judgment there he
did say he regretted endorsing Hillary
Clinton I don't think he's a bad dude I
just think I'd say like this when Trump
said he was going to come out of vaccine
and he said he was going to happen by
the end of the year I said I ain't
taking it
so did Kamala Harris exactly yeah but
you know the whole thing about that
vaccine when he first came out if you
take the vaccine you don't have to
social distance you don't have to wear a
mask
to normal yeah back to normal it was a
great vaccine stop the curve yeah yeah
whatever and then people's getting a
vaccine and people were still getting
sick Oh you if you're vaccinated you
still got a social distance and wear a
mask I'm like wait a minute right that
was the problem Prospect of is this
vaccine if you still have to well 100
safe and effective according to the CEO
advisor and then 98 95 93 92 you see the
news articles going all the way down and
uh yeah we got to go to super chats
we're running a little behind but I
thought that was fun so uh let's jump
into super jets if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only uncensored show coming up I'm going
fast because we went six minutes over we
were talking it was fun so uh let's
let's read some super chats from you
guys and smash that like button thanks
so much we got a lot we had Alex here
graphy says let the fun begin but but
appreciate it
what do we got flooded timber Farm says
would love to see you guys hire the lady
that was fired from that gaming company
do you guys hear that some woman was
following Ian miles Chong and Libs of
tick tock so they fired her what that's
so insane isn't it I don't know I think
she's I think you could look it up
followers but I think she's Canadian we
can't I don't know if she's not Canadian
you know we can try and figure something
out but we can't hire Canadians
unfortunately wait a minute not
following in the car not following on
foot following them on social media
that's right yeah and she was fired
that's right yeah isn't that weird that
is not weird like the Media Matters
people follow you guys should they be
fired it's crazy that's crazy it's a
cult man
all right it says if you're stalk at a
person but you follow them on social
media you get fired yeah yeah Stephen
Frost says Timmy you and the team should
look into limited run games firing an
employee because of a My Little Pony fan
getting offended I wish I made that up
it did not make it up
well people are leaving Twitter because
of free speak so that's right it makes
sense it's not like they're actually
moving in beside you you can block them
but no I have to leave all right Matt
Field says what happened to Tim today
he's got one leg entirely off the fence
he's not censoring himself he's naming
the cultists what happened uh I don't I
don't know I felt like today was pretty
routine I did three more segments than I
than I did like at the end of 20 and for
after 2021 I cut out three segments I
started doing again today because I just
felt like it was fun but uh I felt it
was pretty routine other than this
Saturday we're all gonna come hang out
in DC's Freedom Plaza it's gonna be
legit so if you're a skateboarder a
blader a scooter a bmxer if you got a
pogo stick or Moon boots you name it
come hang out it's gonna be fun we got
we got those uh there's boots with like
Springs on them and they're like we
can't get them to work but you're
supposed to be able to like do flips and
stuff if you got those bring them on
down man we're gonna we're gonna hang
out we got the moon boots they're more
for like just working out and bouncing
but I wanted the kangaroo boots where
you can really get like six feet and do
flips I don't know if those are the
rights oh they have like yep so I'm like
yeah it's like yeah yeah people can be
falling down sign a waiver have you guys
ever seen extreme Pogo yeah they do
backflips on pogo sticks they're like
bouncing 12 feet in the air it's crazy
but anyway it's Saturday coming to bring
back roller derby roller Derby's big
yeah they got shops popping up all over
really oh yeah like you used to if you
guys got quads and you want to come and
you want to quad around man we're we're
big fans of that too I just you know
people we're out there to have a good
time on a Saturday have fun come do your
thing there's no official event we're
not doing anything I'm just saying I'm
gonna be there and in my car I'm gonna
have a whole bunch of Tim cast
skateboards that I don't want to carry
around and I'll probably just give away
to whoever's there hold on 10 a.m right
yeah 10 a.m all right 10 a.m you heard
there I saw it in the chat we're asking
what time 10 a.m yep Eastern 10 a.m and
uh it's gonna be fun and we're gonna
film and uh we're just gonna be chilling
because I was there last weekend having
a good time minding my own business and
uh I intend to do the same thing next
next week again is roller derby Where
They smash into each other
but but sort of it's like yeah it's it's
a bit rough I think the goal is to like
you're trying to outlap it's a race yeah
I don't know if race is the right word
it's like a point systems too right yeah
and it's like you're trying to like
bypass someone to get a pointer were
people getting injured is that why yeah
people's getting missed yeah for real
it's a lot of high-speed bones it's like
10 times worse is hockey yeah yeah all
right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim the
truth of the matter is that we are many
we are stronger than we realize stronger
than they can ever imagine the cult
would cower if all of us spoke out be
strong people we will win
that's what I'm saying man dude when I
hear that so many skateboarders are like
yeah I'm just tired of getting messages
from skateboarders look man I love you
guys the people who you know you know
who you are my friends and they're
they're you know people across the
industry and they're just like I really
wish someone else would speak out it's
like okay dude well look I'm not a pro
skater but I'm sitting right here
screaming at High Heavens
and I'm gonna keep doing it and we're
gonna we're gonna keep pushing and we're
not gonna but where where are y'all at
right where's that like here's the funny
thing the rollerbladers
they got no issue because they got
nothing to lose the rollerblade industry
is like just non-existent but right
right so like we've had Pro
rollerbladers come out just be like big
fan love it and I'm like you're not
worried about getting cancer and they're
like getting cancer from what
BMX there's two and I like we had one
dude get kind of offended yeah he was
like what does that mean I'm like I was
like well I think like smaller the
smaller Action Sports Industries have
let you have lots to fear some of these
skateboarders they make like 80 000 a
year and that's really really good if
and they're like I can't lose it it's my
job right right you know but no we gotta
we gotta just we got to show them that
we're here to have fun
no hate no politics just skate I'll come
down I'll do some gnarly hard flips uh
you guys can bring your scooters
whatever you want to bring and your
blades your boards and it'll just be a
good time yeah go bring Trump Flags
Love Is Love yeah yeah love it's love
that's it you know we'll bring we'll
bring some skateboards all right
non-existent Homestead says Luke got it
backwards the FBI does not work for the
White House the White House works for
the FBI good point
um yeah I conceded
the FBI works for the CIA is that also
confirmed as Jagger Hoover was basically
under blackmail which of those guys
there's a bigger institution above all
of them kind of calling the shots here
but uh I I think the commenter made a
good point how can you have a hearing at
the uh in in and say these words I
cannot confirm or deny how you get away
with that oh the if bad about the yeah
right Yips yeah I can't confirm or deny
yeah
is that the same thing as pleading the
fifth yeah basically basically all right
Max Redick says Tim you said an earlier
segment today that people need to stop
being afraid and speak up I agree please
call out Sam Cedar for his BS we need
this for the culture War he's always
bashing you he's not that damn theater
yeah you guys know is that the guy who
he came involved with uh um Stephen
Crowder that's right they did a bait and
switch with that other guy with the
eyebrow action and so this is why like I
have no no problem with with like
mentioning him you you want us to talk
about it listen the dude his whole stick
is trying to get attention he's sadly
desperate he did a voice on Bob's
Burgers and they and they started
cutting his character out and he was
losing it he does the every Bob's
Burgers yeah Sam Cedar is the voice of
the health inspector and I remember I
was talking to him once and he was like
yeah but they were not they're like
they're like wheezing me out of the show
man he's like he's getting bummed about
it so what does he do no I mean I'd be
bummed too I mean I feel it for him like
he's he's like trying to be a voice
actor he's trying to do comedy he's
trying to be a comedian right and then
they start saying like you know what
we're not going to use this character
anymore and the character works I think
in the show like I'm not a big fan of
Bob's Burgers but having that conflict
with a guy comes and gives him beef yeah
he's getting bummed about it so what do
I see him do later it kind of bums me
out this is the the first guy ever to
give me a shout out with Sam's here
first person ever I'm at Occupy Wall
Street I'm filming and Sam Cedar goes on
the shows assistant pool guy no how
about that
then you see him go down this route
where it's like
he does every other video is like Dave
Rubin or me or something it's like he
doesn't talk about anything substantive
it's like almost all the content is just
like please please look at me I'll talk
about you I think so people are like Tim
you got to call him out why man it's sad
he's a dude who got cut from a cartoon
show yeah lately they've been doing I
think I think Sam's really great
actually I really like I think he's
really intelligent and uh he he made a
observation about something we were
talking about a show lately a Show's
been pretty interesting pretty pretty
observant and him and Emma were talking
about uh when we were over TP USA and
how we were talking about occupy and
saying that wokeism came in and
destroyed the movement like you couldn't
even they wouldn't let me speak because
I was white they're like we've had too
many white people speak to the media and
he was like Tim remember you guys
remember it was the cops that ended with
Occupy Wall Street it was the
authoritarian Crackdown leave all the
other stuff away don't blame and point
fingers it was the cops remember what
ended that movement it wasn't nice the
cops came in and kicked everyone out of
the car oh I was there no no no no no no
they did that but there were
Libertarians and conservatives I met
Luke at Occupy Wall Street and they got
chased out by crackpot Marxist well the
market thing works it started putting
all the white people black people and
Asian people in separate groups to vote
based on race but that didn't stop it I
was there for that I was stubborn I
stayed no one chased me out what stopped
the movement was when you had an actual
populist wave and I'll throw shade to
the right because I told this is Steve
Bannon I said if you went down there and
you actually gave support to the people
who are complain about the banks you
would have had a true populist movement
but the right was too busy making fun of
Occupy Wall Street then the marxists
came in because the right was like don't
look your Hannity was like they're so
stupid don't look at them they're crap
on cop cars and I'm like well all the
conservatives left the first the like
the first weekend I was there there was
an old couple sitting on a couch with an
American flag behind them and they were
conservatives and they were like look we
don't know but the banks got bailed out
and the people got screwed the old
people couldn't stay and stick around
and the young people with trust funds
could and so the non-profits came in the
marxists the quote cult started coming
in and then within a month and a half
they went from everyone come and share
your ideas too if you're black you go in
that group if you're white you you get
no group if you're Asian you're in that
group you're Mexican you're in that
group and then you vote based on your
race I agree but I think the point he's
making is remember who the enemy was in
that situation for all of us it was
Federal Reserve it was the big business
interests that also broke up the
movement they came in with cops but the
problem was at that point the whole
thing was corrupt you had the general
Union and the general assembly fighting
each other two different factions the
east and west side of the parks in
disagreement the general Union which
you're not going to read about in the
Occupy books because they will lie and
claim it never happened were regular
people sleeping intense living in the
park who said the structure they've
built is wrong they said the general
Union Guys these are like Lefty
anti-establishment guy said the family
unit is the most important so the form
of government we want for occupy is that
each tent is a family and then the
family sends their representative to the
general assembly that's Central planning
man and what and what the general
assembly said was we should change to a
spokesman Council system where we create
groups based on your race or gender or
identity and that's what destroyed
everything because I watched people
leave crying I'm I meet this guy
lucrakowski and Anarchist certainly not
a leftist because in the beginning
everybody was like the bouts are bad the
war is bad Obama is bad and then the
woke cult came in
destroyed it and I wish someone like
Bannon and other people on the right
would have come in and or Breitbart and
been like yeah you know what we agree
with the message opposing the big Banks
and the establishment in the elites
instead they backed off made fun of them
let uh what's his name uh Jack Donaghey
a Baldwin Baldwin show up and then a
bunch of Lefty celebrities came in and
they seeded that whole thing to the cult
Peter Schiff came down there to troll
and make fun of people for
that's not a video yeah anyway that's my
point look dude
I I I've done a debate with Sam Cedar he
didn't know what solipsism was he didn't
know what deontological uh moral
philosophy was he didn't know what
utilitarian utilitarianism meant he said
he's an actor first and sure and so
people are supposed to be like why am I
going to talk about a guy whose whole
bit is making fun of people on YouTube
what we're talking about this whole time
is cultural battles Supreme Court we're
talking about politicians but people I
bring this up Max because other people
mention it like get into a battle with
him well there you go I just gave you
your battle right I'm not interested in
in having it out with a YouTuber he'll
make he'll make 12 more videos about me
so all The Young Turks will mention them
young picks love you it's it's it's it's
it's stupid yeah and there's no no look
there's no there's no wonder why we had
you know 50 000 people watching the show
tonight and they get seven thousand
because who cares about me it's like
like Are you seriously like you know
we're talking about Joe Biden having
classified documents everybody's like I
want to hear that what's going on with
Joe Biden imagine if I did a show and
I'm like did I chose about a guy you
never heard of yeah you know what's so
crazy they're attacking you for your
opinions and but they don't don't want
to point out the obvious hypocrisy of
the of Democrats in in the media in
general it's like you doing your thing
you're spreading your opinions but they
don't care anything what our
government's doing is wrong they'd
rather attack another fellow YouTuber
who might have different opinions it's
just it is it's naive you know maybe
their argument is well we are the you
know biggest live show on average so
that's the target but it's just like but
that's because we don't talk we don't
get into the drama weeds we like we talk
about ideas and I think regular factual
and you live in reality that's why I
suppose so for a lot of people that's
that's probably the case but let's uh
let's let's uh we'll move on from that
all right Jessie J says Ian is like a
dude that while filling out a form and
it asks in what city he lives he doesn't
know how to proceed because he lives in
a town not a city commande and you get
the idea
semantics
perfect semantics yeah yeah I have a
problem with this form it says which
city I don't live in and say I live in a
village
yeah I don't like to put my race on
those things I put other yeah I don't
know what to call my I don't know well I
was I was told when I was a kid that if
I put my actual race I'd be
discriminated against white and Asian
because Asians are a lot discriminated
against than white people of course
y'all have the best high key scores so
yeah we've got all kinds of privilege I
was told to lie and say I was Mexican
when I was a kid yeah
yeah and I was like no I'm not
interested in that I'm I'm you know
happy to say that I'm you know Park
Korean all right my nephew's Korean yeah
I like I'm not going to live in a world
where people tell me I have to pretend
I'm not yeah I'm not white like get it
through your thick not you forget it get
out of your big skull white I've got
color in my skin it's like a pinkish
yeah one in 21 million says here's a 20
for Ian Roland 20s by Bitcoin oh there
you go I don't think we have to buy them
yet
yeah all right unless we might have some
more it's good we're getting close
I am what I am says here's your weekly
white pill even with everything going on
we still live in the most amazing place
and wonderful time we should speak out
from a place of love compassion never
fear your own voice I think that's a
very very important point to be made
nice like we got something done we got
toilets full of fresh water we can take
a dump in and literally flush down the
toilet like their place in the world
where there's no water yeah it's not so
bad here but that's kind of the point
that's why we're we're standing up for
what we believe in because we don't want
to lose that we got it good we do and
they would rather you owe nothing you'll
be happy they say
Aldo says saw you guys in Bakersfield it
was a damn good show that joke about
juicy finishing his sandwich after the
modern country incident dude couldn't
resist a six-inch couldn't he got my car
vandalized that night that's ca for you
there you go man and crazy stories you
guys see that story out of Houston where
the dude I think it was Houston he
shoots the robber yes is that the one we
shot him nine times or eight times
execution style it was an execution
style that last shot if it walks across
the room puts one in his head whereas
he's already on the ground like
completely still so he gets Rob he
shoots him nine times and then shoot
some Mexican a guy breaks into a a
restaurant and starts robbing every one
of the guy is watching him it's like a
gun and yeah with a gun so the dude open
holding like concealed pulls it out and
hits him four times the guy drops the
gun goes flying and then he walks
towards him hits him four more on his
way towards him and then walks towards
him again and then he walks right up to
one in the head you're like dude that's
not legal in a lot of places because
once in a lot of places if they're no
longer a threat threat has been
neutralized you don't keep shooting
in some cities but I'm speaking morally
and ethically like the situation is I do
not believe it's incumbent upon the
victims to determine when they like when
someone threatens to murder or execute
them when they're supposed to just be
like I'm not like here's my point this
guy was apparently was a BB gun that's
not that's not the victim's problem
these people are all victimized this guy
when you point a gun at someone you have
explicitly stated I will end your life
right now you can't tell nowadays no BB
guns they're exact replicas of attack
Firearms especially when you get rid of
that except for that orange tip so so a
lot of people didn't understand there's
tons of videos you watch them where the
cops will you know be attacked by a guy
they'll shoot him and he won't go down
right and there was one video where a
guy had a knife and the cop shoots him
like three times and the guy staggers
and then starts lunging forward the
knife and the cop screaming no no no and
then he shoots him in the head it's like
dude just because the guy's on the
ground he's holding a gun just because
he's shot doesn't mean he can't go like
this and take the gun and shoot a kid in
the head yeah but he like this
particular since the gun goes out of his
hand after the fourth shot it's and so
the guy walks up he kicks it you can
watch the video it's on Twitter he
actually kicks the gun away too yeah I
think that's it and takes it away and
puts it on the and then I know after
this ninth right right there could have
been another guy there casing it you
know you never know what you're up
against that's an important distinction
from what I said saw he shoots him gets
him on the ground and then unloads and
that's it because this is a longer video
he was ending the threat yeah the longer
video I highly recommend is he getting
arrested no please please the police are
looking for him but they're not charging
him right now
and I think I think you watch the video
and it's clear-cut self-defense I think
it's horrible that it happened but it's
clear-cut self-defense yeah if you kind
of agree with that like I'm like if
someone threatens to murder people kill
them on the spot no matter how many
shots it like why would you not uh
particularly if they're expressing the
means to do so a guy with his fists up
who's like oh I'm gonna go do this yeah
you might want to try and something like
guns at people's heads and stuff exactly
yeah that's a slippery slope too if if
say they do prosecute that guy right and
they take it to court and this it sets a
evil precedent against anybody that's
trying to defend their own life so so
let's say they they pull up another
scenario where they keep shooting it and
the guy throws the gun and he keeps
shooting them and he didn't see it and
he actually end up Prosecuting based on
this one president case I don't I think
that's a fine line it's a slippery slope
you nobody that's a second amendment
Advocate wants to go down because yeah
because it says Sacramento you have the
right to defend your your life protect
your life it doesn't mean shoot the name
or anything like shoot the kill I got an
idea I was thinking about that's talking
to Luke about this
if you have a right you have the right
to vote right can they charge you money
to vote
I'm pretty sure the poll tax was deemed
unconstitutional yeah yeah right so why
is that the government can charge me
money for a permit to own a firearm
right how about
somebody who lives in a state that
requires permitting
tell the government they have to give
you the permit free of charge because
it's a right you recognize they can
require a permit but that it's it's at
their expense not yours because they are
the ones who want you permitted and it's
your right that's the same logic that
Democrats are using with the vote to
have ID to vote Yes No Las Vegas you
don't have to have an ID to vote there
then I believe it's unconstitutional to
require someone to pay money for a
permit I think permits are
unconstitutional but let's start from
here anybody who lives in a state that
charges money for permitting Maryland
file a lawsuit call it call one of these
two-way advocacy groups hit me up one
like if you're one of these
organizations and let's talk about this
because I think we could easily win in
the Supreme Court especially right now
if we get a case that says you can't
charge money for someone to exercise a
right right yeah it's like imagine if
it's like you want to play the fifth
that'll be twenty dollars sir no no no
no you want to keep them bear arms
that'll be 500 sir nope nope nope that
means NFA items you want me to uh if I
want to get a silencer if I want to get
a machine gun NFA tax and permit
unconstitutional you can cannot charge
someone money to exercise a right hey
that's your Korean side right there yo
you know it yeah I've never heard
anybody come with that argument it
sounds like a very very valid argument
see West Virginia though is
constitutional carry um you don't need a
permit yeah they outright just say no
you're good you have to have it exposed
though right not concealed no no no no
no no no yeah yeah oh really West
Virginia if you're a resident you walk
in you show me your ID the federal law
still applies for a background check the
West Virginia's chill you get you you
can get your gun as soon as you're
cleared then you can holster it right
underneath your shirt and walk right out
oh that's good New Hampshire is the same
way you can open and thank you you got
to have a permit to conceal yeah and
that's what I'm saying same with Florida
and you guys should figure out if
there's a gun rights group or something
advocacy group file a lawsuit and be
like you can't charge money the courts
have already ruled I think it was
Kavanaugh you can require a permit okay
well then why am I paying for it right
no no you got to pay for it right that's
my right you're the one who wants to put
a barrier on me I want exercise my right
I'll accept your barrier if you pay for
it now that means anything you want to
get you saw that hassle but we'll work
we'll work towards and then eventually
we'll get permitting made illegal
because the Constitution is a permit
right all right let's read this one
Nikki bem says Ian you have so much more
to unfold with Kinsey and look into John
money they're Heroes to them and out sex
ed is uh and our sex that is based off
of it yeah John money's crazy yeah
you're gonna love that yeah for real I
worked with a guy named John money in La
it's so funny really an actor yeah
drawing money huh this John money was a
New Zealand psychologist and sexologist
and he and he forcefully surgically
altered a child and then both these kids
killed themselves oh he's like the
father of the idea of gender is that
right we have sex sexual identity two
twin two twin boys one had a a
mouth had a circumcision mishap yeah so
then he was like we're gonna all
medically alter that that little boy
into a girl socialize him and don't
worry gender is a social construct both
both those kids grew up in committed
suicide wow yeah even the boy he would
make them simulate banging each other
like other weird messed up stuff so wild
dude you have to read it to really
believe it even all right gpt3bot says
Tim run Roberto Jr for president under
the slogan the buck buck stops here I'll
vote for him here's a few Buck bucks for
y'all we're gonna do a Roberto Jr pro
model for our skateboard company
our rooster is going to have his own Pro
board and then we'll put uh all his uh
his royalties will go towards improving
chicken City oh hell yeah
yeah I gotta get any point out of that
if you make it this one's a brutal one
essay federally says Tim said something
about bottom surgery you mean General
mutilation being for someone else's
gratification recently we need to call
them coconuts in Dane Cook's joke MFC
people are getting duped into being sex
dolls here's what I said
someone like uh Jazz Jennings is born
male and then gets put on puberty
blockers and female hormones when Jazz
was 17 they were like we're going to do
bottom surgery they called it to create
a um what are they what do they call it
a pseudo vagina I mean you want a
YouTube term wound I think yeah there
you go so this is the issue
it is it is a it is a wound literally in
medical I'm not saying it's be mean it's
in medical terminology it is a wound
where they graft it's an open wound they
graft intestinal material into for one
purpose oh yeah so someone else can
place their penis inside of it for
sexual gratification does it get wet
I don't know all I know is it's it's
something I think people need to
consider when they're talking to their
to their to their kids
it actually might that's why they graft
colon into it oh man that's what I'm
saying and it serves one purpose yeah
there's no kids coming from this it's
right and and it's just so that another
human being who wants to insert
themselves into the wound can feel
sexual gratification and why would you
want to do that stick it hey man I think
you're gay already just go ahead and put
it
you know man but we got it we have a big
story that we'll talk about the members
only pretending to Chicago and this huge
Scandal is exposed I think it's gonna
get pretty brutal so we'll read one more
we got long Joseph says my dad fell over
from a heart attack when I was 15. they
said he could live but would be vegetal
due to head trauma I just needed a
minute three year daily listener thanks
for all you guys do
sorry to hear it man it's it's it's
tough stuff all right all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com because we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show coming up
at about 11 p.m and a huge library and
we're going to talk a lot about some
dark stuff so you're not going to want
to miss it it'll probably be sad it'll
be funny it'll be disturbing all of
those things you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me at timcast
Hodge twins you wanna shout anything out
um yeah you can follow us on YouTube
conservative plans there you go easy
enough all right are you guys on Twitter
yeah under Hawks wins well thank you
guys so much for coming out this was
really fun uh it was really a funny
conversation and I really enjoyed your
guys's uh energy here it was pretty cool
so thank you so much for coming out uh
my website is Luke uncensored.com I did
a very important video today about the
many coincidences happening all over the
world and uh when you sign up to Lucan
sensor.com you not only get exclusive
videos and merchandise you also get to
be a part of a community I'm answering
all of your questions right now check
all that out be a part of the
conversation Luke uncensored.com see you
there uh awesome show man and I wanted
to show you this and also you guys out
there I got this as a gift over the
holidays there's seven of them they're
chakra tuning Forks you have uh this
piece oh here we go take a rubber mallet
and you ding it
and then you stick it on your head
you're supposed to hold it at the bottom
yeah
uh I I I've been dude you gotta hold at
the bottom dude it's a tuning no no it
mutes it if you hold it down here that
that blocks is so right no it literally
just ranged this ring it didn't ring
before yeah you got to hold it at the
bottom but what you want to do is touch
it to your body it's called The Healing
Sound Energy I had a couple hippies do
this to me a couple years you can't hold
it there trust me guys I've been doing
this you want to touch it to your head
you touch it to the shock right each one
is
dude it's
been a while it's opened up my sinuses I
was doing it what I dang it I rang it
and that was like within 20 seconds just
sinuses
and then do that you stick the metal to
your head so I was doing it on my right
on my third eye let's do it the way Ian
said to do it yeah
[Laughter]
that's the thing but then when you touch
it to your head it vibrates a resonating
frequency uh-huh
nothing's happening now you got to hit
yourself over the head ding it in front
of me do it hit it like right on the
cranium vibrates the skull graphene yeah
that's what I'm talking about it figured
it out where'd you get that I got it as
a Christmas gift for my mother I bought
on Amazon here check it out a new track
anytime anywhere see you guys yeah sir
do you want to talk us out while we're
yeah what's up guys I'm at surge.com
follow me on Instagram and Twitter I
rarely plug myself this seriously but uh
I want some dopamine points from uh the
extra numbers on the screen so there you
go give me one thank you yeah YouTube
analytics are all wonky right now I'm
watching it and they're all wrong yeah
so uh head over to Tim I see people
becoming members on YouTube I always got
to stress this go to timcast.com click
join us and become a member at
timcast.com where we will post on the
front page you'll see it in the left
uncensored members only with the Hodge
twins that should be up around 11
because we're gonna record it right now
thanks for hanging out everybody and we
will see you all over at the members
only show
[Music]
laughs